Three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're live.
Hello,
Gary Hydro.
Thanks for coming man.
Appreciate it.
My pleasure.
The case against sugar.
Yeah.
This is a for me.
This is a up.
I don't know how to put this any other
way.
I've,
I've kind of consumed sugar most of my
life until the last couple of years and
I slowly sort of tapered off and about
about a year ago,
maybe last February or so.
I just pretty much cut it all out except
for the occasional occasional dessert
here.
They're infinitely better quality of
life.
I feel much better.
I have more energy and then I started
really getting into it and then I came
across your work and um,
what I want to know is first of all,
how did you get involved in this and how
much resistance have you fixed?
Okay.
This being the sugarcane,
this being the whole obesity diet,
nutrition,
we can get into all of it,
but the sugar one to me is absolutely
fascinating when you go down.
I mean,
if you've seen that sugar movie.
Yeah,
yeah.
Probably in it I think.
I think you ought to come onto the
talking cereal boxes.
Oh,
okay.
Right now,
um,
I will,
I've watched it with my kids.
I'm,
I made my kids watch it and it's amazing
when,
you know,
a six year old watches,
something like that.
And then they go,
why is sugar in everything?
You know,
it's funny because my kids lived with
this all the time,
right.
So we had just come back from spending
the holidays with my grandmother who
pumps them up with sugar while we're
there and there's nothing I can do with
it.
Then we'd get back and I'm having them
making my boy's dinner.
They're eight and 11 and uh,
my wife's out and after the dinner,
my eight year old says or weakened
desert and my 11 year old goes,
yeah,
nic,
it's dad,
man,
are you crazy?
Wake up son.
Anyway,
I got into this,
you know,
I.
okay.
I was a physics major in college.
Shows was like hard science and then I
wasn't any good at.
I got a c minus and quantum physics and
my advisor suggested I find another
career.
So went into journalism,
started doing science writing in the
early eighties because it was the only
work I could get.
And then my first book I went to live at
cern,
the big particle accelerator lab outside
of Geneva and I was what we would call
today embedded with the physicists and I
thought it was going to be following.
I'm making this great discovery,
which is what the Nobel laureate who ran
the experiment was predicting and
instead I spent 10 months watching them
figure out how they screwed up.
Okay.
And it was a learning experience in how
to do science right.
And I was obsessed with how hard it is
to do good science and I had a lot of
the physicists in the world really
didn't like this Nobel laureate,
so they were happy to point out to me
how he was screwing up and how he
screwed up in the past and how he even
screwed up the work that he won the
Nobel prize for.
Um,
after I came back I thought that was
actually paid six and the New York Post,
when my book came out,
the headline was Aig had over Nobel
prize and this Nobel laureate who was
calling me an asshole in the newspaper
and I'm 29 years old.
Nice.
Assume my Jordan,
you know,
my career over.
What was he calling you?
An asshole over.
Well,
because I ended up writing an expo say,
but what a bad scientist.
He was about the politics of science,
you know,
I thought I was,
I went to Stockholm with this guy when
he won the Nobel prize.
I mean we got our talks is fitted
together.
I was a guest at the Nobel dinner and
the Nobel banquet and the party that
follows,
which is the most fun I've ever had in
my life.
Um,
students,
Stockholm,
throw a party for the laureates and
it's,
back then it was crazy.
Um,
anyway,
so he was justifiably pissed off that I
just wrote what I saw instead of what a
great man he thought he was.
And I thought my career was going to be
over right.
You're called an asshole.
And the papers when you were 29 year old
journalists by Nobel laureate,
but instead everybody I would interview
in science would say,
Oh,
you think that guy was bad,
you should write about this guy.
And I just started covering different
aspects and it turns out you could get
along way in science if you're willing
to sort of cut corners.
And then it's not actually cheating,
it's just you could discover a lot of
stuff if you're not willing to do the
rigorous,
hard,
critical,
skeptical work to demonstrate that.
Would you say you have discovered is
wrong.
Okay.
So I wrote a book about something called
Cold Fusion,
which was a great scientific fiasco of
the 20th century except for the stuff
I'm writing about now.
And some of my friends in the physics
community said,
if you're interested in bad science book
was called bad science.
He said,
you should look at this stuff in public
health because it's terrible.
And so I moved into public health
beginning with this idea that
electromagnetic fields from power lines
will cause brain cancer,
leukemia and everything.
I had learned about what you,
how rigorous and meticulous and
skeptical and thoughtful you had to do
to get the right answer and physics.
The public health people didn't think it
had to do.
They thought it was kind of a luxury
because their science is harder and it
is kind of harder.
You're dealing with like chronic
diseases that happen over decades and
people and messy systems and you can't
measure anything and everything I had
learned was that if you don't do this
stuff,
you get the wrong answer.
So by the late nineties I had stumbled
into nutrition research and this is
maybe a longer story than you want it.
No,
I was living here in Venice,
California.
I was freelancing for the journal
Science,
so was what's called a contributing
correspondent and I needed a paycheck to
pay my rent.
So I called my editor and I said,
what do you got?
What kind of story could I turn over
quickly?
And he said there was a diet study that
was coming out in the New England
Journal of Medicine in two weeks and
they want to do an article about him and
I didn't know is that this diet study
had been leaked to science and advance
and the person who leaked that had given
them a list of sources to talk to who
leaks a diet study right,
to a trial.
And this was a dash diet,
dietary approaches to stop hypertension,
which is the most today,
US news and World Report says it's the
healthiest diet in the world based on,
you know,
like force studies that did not
demonstrate anything.
Um,
the way you do those stories as a
journalist is you interview the
principal investigator and you ask him
who to talk to when he gives you a
couple of names to talk to who can talk
about the study even though it's
published.
And then you get three interviews,
which is enough to justify a page in the
magazine and you get your paycheck.
Um,
so I interviewed the Pie and then I
interviewed one of the people on the
list of documents that had been leaked
to science and that was a former
president of the American heart
association,
and she told me she couldn't talk about
this study or she'd lose her funding.
And I said,
come on man,
this isn't Sanko era.
Soviet Union people don't lose their
funding for talking to a journalist
about a diet study.
And she refused to talk to me.
I said,
let's go off the record,
complete confidentiality if I'm going to
miss a story that you're not telling me
that's bad,
couldn't get her to talk.
And then I call one of the people that
the Pi told me to talk to and he sounded
exactly like Walter Matthau on the other
side of the telephone was very weird and
Walter's starts yelling at me that
there's no controversy over solid and
high blood pressure.
And I'm going.
But Walter,
I'm not calling about salt and high
blood pressure.
I'm calling about this dash diet coming
out.
And these keeps going on.
There's no controversy,
there's no evidence.
It's all doesn't cause high blood
pressure.
So I get off the phone,
I call up my editor,
I said I'm going to finish this story,
but I had this former Aha presidency.
She couldn't talk to me and if she loses
her funding.
And then I had Walter Matthau yelling at
me that um,
there's no controversy over in the high
blood pressure.
There must be a controversy over whether
salt causes high blood pressure.
Right?
So I'm going to turn this story and pay
my rent.
And then I spent the next nine months
doing an investigation for science.
I interviewed I think 85 sources for one
magazine article.
Got paid for like six weeks,
pissed off my fiance at the time because
she thought she's going to date someone.
They should have a better sort of,
you know,
work efficiency ratio.
Um,
the conclusion was that the only way you
would believe that salt causes high
blood pressure from the studies that had
been done to that point was if God told
you so perf personally.
So you could ignore all the evidence and
all the randomized control trials name
and the observational evidence.
And just,
but that's what everyone had done.
Well,
how did this start?
Because I had heard that before as well.
Everybody's heard that before and I had
read a long time ago that that was
bullshit and that salt is actually an
essential mineral and it's important for
your body and it doesn't cause high
blood pressure and there's a host of
other factors should be considered.
So it was,
yeah,
that's the thing.
It was kind intuitively.
It was an interesting idea.
Make biological sense.
When you consume salt,
you also have to take in water.
That's why they feed pretzels and you
know,
salty peanuts at bars because you want
to take in liquids so that you can
maintain the same sodium concentration
in your blood because your cells like
the,
you know,
the chemical reactions that drive your
cells are dependent on the sodium ratio
in the cells.
So if you take in more salt,
you're going to drink more fluid and
that you're going to have in a more
fluid in your circulation.
That's going to increase your blood
pressure.
And it does happen in a very short term.
But the question is this,
a chronic cause of high blood pressure
and hypertension and once the
researchers decided was,
and these guys are terrible scientists,
I mean,
I hate to say this,
but in my first book,
good calories,
bad calories,
in the epilogue,
I pointed out,
I say,
you know,
I never used the word scientist to
describe any of these people doing
research except for a few specific
examples because they don't really
understand what science is and how to do
it.
And they weren't to their defense,
they just were never taught how to be
scientists or physicians and
nutritionists who had a sloppy
scientific training and they thought it
was easy and you get a hypothesis and
you confirm the hypothesis.
And when he didn't confirm it,
they thought it must be true anyway.
And then you find the data.
When people talk about Cherry picking,
that means you find that data that does
sort of confirm and you ignore the rest.
So anyway,
that was it.
I wrote this article is called the
political science of salt,
you know,
won some awards.
And while I was doing that,
uh,
it's Walter Matthau character took
credit not just for getting Americans to
eat less salt,
putting us on this low salt diet.
He took credit for getting us on the low
fat diet that we were all waiting in the
nineties and I got off the phone with
them,
called my editor at science and I said,
when I'm done writing about salt,
I'm going to write about fat.
I have no idea what the story is,
but this guy is clearly one of the five
were scientists I've ever interviewed in
my life.
And you know,
everything I learned in my physics
period was at bad scientists never get
the right answer.
So I spent a year doing an investigation
for the journal Science on dietary fat
that paid for about two months.
And it seems to be a trend here.
Yeah,
it was bad.
No,
it's good.
It's good.
You got to do that to get the right
answer.
That's.
Yeah.
And that's why so much has journalism is
so shallow is because if you're gonna
put in the time you get paid for,
it's all you can do as a shallow job.
Nobody can afford to do that.
I actually had corporate jobs that
allowed me,
you know,
like writing speeches and press releases
for IBM that,
you know,
I really hated doing,
but that paid well and like that was my
corporate work so I could do the pro
bono stuff I cared about.
Anyway,
that's.
That story was the same unless God told
you personally.
So I ended up doing this cover story for
the New York Times magazine called what
if it's all been a big fat lie,
which came out July 2002.
It was probably the most,
one of the top five most controversial
articles ever ran.
And the idea was I wanted to see what
caused the obesity epidemic.
That was what I pitched to the editor,
but we had this idea that you get fat
from eating dietary fat.
That was actually the primary logic
behind putting the country on low fat
diets.
They thought it might help heart
disease,
but they hadn't been able to show it in
trials,
but they just assumed if we ate less
fat,
we'd lose weight because fat,
denser calories,
and there was always this competing
hypothesis that had been buried and
swept aside and ignored and you know,
inhibited which was at the problem is
the carbohydrates,
particularly sugar and refined grains.
And so when I got this cover story,
I got a big book advance.
Finally I could afford to do the book I
wanted it paid for four years of my
life.
The book took five.
Again,
same financial issues.
But um,
and I love it because people accused me
of like,
I was just going to write anything I
could find for a paycheck.
And I finally got a big paycheck.
And so now one of the ideas there that
emerged out of my research.
So even when I wrote the 2002 piece,
I thought that we got fat because we ate
too much.
You know there's a line in that article
piece to it,
of course has caused by consuming too
many calories and we can more calories
than we consume.
By the time I was done with this book,
I thought that was one of the most inane
scientific ideas that had ever come
along.
I mean,
it's almost incomprehensible to me even
though I know exactly the history of the
idea and where it came from and why we
believe that it's just crazy naive,
so that's the one that I get the
feedback on because I'm out there saying
so 99 percent of obesity researchers and
nutritionists and all our public health
policy is based fundamentally on this
concept that we get because we eat too
much or too sedentary and what I was
saying was not only is that naive and
meaningless,
it's a description.
It's not an explanation and we could go
into that.
Clearly.
Obesity is a hormonal metabolic defect
and in fact the best scientists in the
world prior to World War Two,
the best far and away the best medical
science was done in Germany and Austria
in Europe.
The US was a backwater of medical
science until postwar just,
it was a backwater,
virtually all science and these guys had
concluded that obesity had to be a
metabolic hormonal defect,
but the American doctors were saying,
Oh man,
the hormonal thing obesity's Ramona was
an excuse for fat people to not eat in
moderation and run marathons like a
saline people do,
and what I did is I brought that
hypothesis sort of advantage with the
war literally evaporated with the war.
The German Austrian medical community
evaporated.
We wanted nothing to do with these
researchers.
The Ivy League universities had policies
in place to keep from being overrun by
Jewish academicians from Europe,
so then physics,
we embrace them because we had bombs to
build in a cold war to fight,
but medicine and public health,
we wanted nothing to do with them.
So this hypothesis evaporates and
postwar.
You get this creation of basically
obesity research created Denovo by
these.
Like the young doctors have no
scientific training who are leaving,
who hate the German,
so they're not going to pope the German
literature,
even if they read it and nutritionists
who do animal research and never even
studied obese people.
And you get this idea that it's an
eating.
You know,
it's a calorie overconsumption problem
by the 19 sixties.
The field is dominated by psychologists
and psychiatrists who are studying ways
to get obese people to just stop eating
so damn much.
They didn't try to make them exercise
back then.
That was kind of torture they would push
later.
So this was the thing I get feedback on.
This is why I'm saying,
you know,
the entire medical nutritional obesity,
diabetes,
dogma is based on just a bad idea.
You know,
a failed paradigm and you know,
who's going to accept that coming from a
journalist.
So the answer is either,
you know,
I'm an idiot or I'm self interested and
I'm only making this up to get a
paycheck or just wrong.
Do you feel vindicated?
Or like when you see what's going on now
where it's a pretty much common
knowledge that sugar is terrible for you
and that added sugar is a huge factor in
diabetes and hypertension and heart
disease and obesity and it's pretty much
across the board now.
Did you feel vindicated when you feel
like,
here's the thing that the.
Even though they're public health
organizations that are now saying,
you know,
gotta cut back on the sugar and putting
limits on sugar consumption.
The logic is still that it's just empty
calories.
That's still the logic by who though
they public health authorities,
the researchers.
Why?
Why do they lag so far behind?
Because this is fascinating to me
because I,
I understand that there must be a guy
like you who does what's kind of
ridiculous and spending nine months on
six weeks worth of pay and it does that
kind of shit because otherwise once an
idea is clearly established and gets
repeated,
like salt causes hypertension.
I mean God damn it.
If you ask the average person on the
street,
Hey,
does salt causes high blood pressure?
Oh yeah,
they,
they just say it because it's like sort
of this peripheral idea.
They hear it in the distance,
they don't research it,
they don't really look into it very far
other than maybe they read something
somewhere at one point in time and then
they just decide it's dogma and they
repeat it.
It's so.
It's incredibly difficult once an idea
like that gets established in our
society too to eradicate it.
Right.
But again,
this is the thing,
it's sort of when you live in a
community,
in an institution where everybody
believes exactly what you do and so the
people you respect,
I mean think about it,
the people you respect are the people
who think like you do,
who agree with you on the important
points because you think,
oh,
they're smart.
They get it just like I get it.
So institutions sort of collect group
thing.
It's just a natural emergent phenomenon
from institutions and now if you look at
the data,
you're somebody like me and you come
along and you say,
I don't really buy this idea so that
it's just empty calories.
So I'm going to look at the data and see
what it says,
and now you try to convince your friends
that they're wrong and now you're the
heretic and you're the one who's saying,
you know,
you're getting in arguments with people
and they make people uncomfortable
because you're trying to get them to
change their minds about thumps and they
all believe and they've all been,
you know,
they're successful,
they're promoted,
they're leaders in their field because
they believed this and now you're
telling them that and people do it,
but the,
the,
this just keeps going and going and
going.
And even to the point,
I mean,
just when my sugar book came out,
there was a book called the secret life
of fat written by a phd and it's,
it's as though everything I've done in
the past 15 years just who's never done.
Like somehow she managed to do an entire
book on dietary fat where if anyone said
to her,
talk to Tobbs,
even if he's wrong,
his ideas are worth hearing because
they're,
they're provocative and interesting.
I'm not so sure he's wrong.
She decided not to do it.
So it sort of do you have the two was
her conclusion and effectively it's all,
you know,
again,
it all comes back effectively to energy
balance.
You could talk about the two
overconsumption.
Um,
it's just,
this is what dogmas do.
They just take,
they,
they reproduce themselves,
they continue to grow there like tumors
for that fact,
and they,
they,
they basically fight off all challenges
they absorb around them.
You know,
so somebody starts saying it's something
else.
Eventually,
ideally everything changes.
So we're,
we're definitely winning the sugar
battle.
So in sugar,
even though that the official word is
it's empty calories would just have to
consume less because they have this
dogma that obesity is caused by
consuming too many calories.
So the way that a food influences your
body mass is through its caloric content
or how much of those calories you digest
and absorb.
Because if it's got fiber,
Yo excrete some and that's the,
that's the wisdom of a calorie is a
calorie than the worst you could say
about sugar is that it's empty calories.
It's got no vitamins and minerals,
micronutrients attached.
And so we consume too much of it and
that people say it's the low hanging
fruit,
so it's not that it's uniquely toxic
because of it's uniquely toxic if it
actually causes disease and we can talk
about clearly what I'm saying it causes
than a calorie isn't a calorie.
When you started doing this research and
you started writing this book,
the case against sugar w,
W,
when this was all unfolding in front of
you,
will you,
will you shocked.
I mean,
is this something that you were where
you were saying,
how am I a guy who got a c plus c minus?
I tried to pump you up.
I mean,
how,
how am I the guy who's figuring this
out?
How is this?
Okay?
So I understood why,
but it is weird because again,
I,
you know,
sometimes I was in Washington,
my book tour and I had dinner with the
former chief science medical science and
medical officer with the American
Diabetes Association.
So very influential,
high ranking successful man.
He's completely convinced that I'm
wrong.
And I said,
why you believe this thing that obesity
is caused by eating too much and you
have no idea why you believe it.
So I can tell you exactly the history of
that belief.
Just like if we were talking about
relativity,
we can go back to Einstein and you would
know about Einstein and even if we were
talking quantum physics,
we'd go back to Isenberg and trodden
juror and bore and p and you'd know
about them.
But this belief that you're
fundamentally arguing is right.
You don't understand where it comes
from.
And I can tell you that and I'm going to
give you the documents.
I'm going to give you the papers where
it out competes,
the hormonal metabolic idea,
and I'm going to give you the competing
hypothesis you didn't even know existed
until you and I talked.
You started reading my stuff and it has
zero influence on how this guy thinks.
He's just.
He's so convinced these.
Right?
So that's terrifying.
That's terrifying.
When someone has that kind of influence
over the American people.
Well,
and this is a thing you want somebody
who does at least say Jesus,
you know,
I never thought of that.
Let me at least have them.
Let me read these and get back to you is
what you want them to do.
You want to.
The problem of course is that if he
agrees to this and then he agrees that
you're correct,
everything that he's been saying up
until now has been bullshit and he's
been misleading people.
He has to apologize history as well.
And then once you do that,
you lose your credit.
Like ideally and science here,
you know,
the best scientists,
the ones who say,
you know,
I was just wrong,
right?
And then,
but how they were actually when I was
growing up,
the estimate was five percent of the
scientific community actually does good
science and the other 95 percent are
sort of the chaff out of which you got
to get the wheat.
But um,
yeah,
I mean it's a problem.
I used to joke,
imagine the American Heart Association
writing the press release to say like,
we were wrong about putting everybody on
a low fat diet.
And it was a mistake and we're sorry,
and we apologize and maybe we killed
some of your relatives prematurely.
Maybe the reason you're fat and diabetic
now is because of our advice,
but we got to right now,
they won't do it.
He can't do it.
That's public health wreck.
It's just they can't do it.
It's an untenable.
I mean,
I'll say the same thing if I'm wrong in
my book.
I used to have this argument with my
cofounder of this nutrition science
initiative,
this not for profit.
And I'd say you don't understand if I'm
wrong and the major arguments in this
book,
I mean clearly I'm going to be wrong.
And some of the minor ones and you know,
chip away here and there are bad
scholarship that I should have tripled
checked.
But if I'm wrong in the major arguments,
I need a new line of work because I can
trust my judgment.
And everything I do as an investigative
journalist is dependent on me being able
to trust my judgment.
And if I'm wrong about this,
like if I'm wrong about energy balance,
I got to go sell shoes.
You know,
there's no way around it,
but this is.
I lost track.
What were we saying?
What was the question?
I talked too much.
Well,
I was asking you first of all,
what is it like to have this
understanding that all of what's being
told to the American people is wrong and
then you having this conversation.
So how do I,
how do I do it?
How do I do?
Am I getting
this?
So let me tell you why I was able to do
what.
And again,
I was the first person who ever did.
It's just that simple.
No one had ever done before,
but it was timing.
First of all,
I'm an obsessive research or is 145
people I interviewed for the fat story
for one magazine Article.
I just keep asking questions and probing
and probing until every ism like
writing.
So it's a great research.
It's a procrastination tool,
but when I started this in 2002,
when I got the money to do the book,
the Internet had come along and the
Internet made it possible to find every
single primary source.
Going back to the 19th century,
like now,
you could almost download them,
but back then I had researchers,
young students in in Boston,
New York,
La,
whose only job was.
They'd get an email from me with 50
citations and then they'd go to the
library and have to find every,
all 50 in xerox them and then ship them
back to me sometimes entire books from
like,
you know,
19,
17 diabetes textbook that I couldn't
find or I couldn't buy and bookstores
had put their used bookstores,
put their catalogs online so you could
find all the books and you know,
some 19,
47 obesity conference.
The library that has it doesn't see any
purpose for that anymore.
So they basically give it to the local
bookstore and you can buy it for seven
bucks.
So I was able to recreate the history of
obesity research from conference
proceedings were the only people doing
research in the field would show up and
they would present their findings and
then they would do a proceedings of the
findings and I could recreate all the
thinking in the field and nobody had
ever bothered to do it before and it's
kind of if they were good scientists,
they would have because they would have
been obsessed with where their beliefs
came from and they would have been
questioning them and one of the things
they would have done is gone back to do
all this to see if some assumption they
believe is true is really based on fact.
But again,
they didn't really know what science
was.
They weren't all that curious is one way
to put it.
That's so terrifying.
It is.
It's so terrifying.
When you know you,
you think of what people.
Most people are busy.
They work all day.
They have families,
they have jobs,
they have obligations.
They don't have the time to do the
research that you did about diet and
come to these shocking conclusions
themselves.
It's not going to happen,
but then they rely on the people like
this guy from the diabetes association
that's supposed to be telling you the
truth and looking at the truth and he
doesn't want to do it because it makes
them look like an asshole.
Well,
and you will also rely on,
I mean these are so they read the review
articles and the reviewers and the
editors of the journals want to get
influential review articles,
so they ask influential people in the
field to do the review articles and
those people are very busy,
but they're going to do with and they're
gonna.
Basically.
They became influential by believing the
conventional wisdom and propagating the
conventional wisdom.
When you have committees do
investigations,
so every five years you get the dietary,
the Usta puts together a committee to
reassess the dietary guidelines that
they give out.
So the way the committees are formed,
they usta picks a very influential
person.
The most influential.
They get to be the head of the committee
and that's somebody who's believed the
conventional wisdom and propagate it
their whole life.
That's how they became influential and
then person picks people they respect to
be on the committee and of course the
people they respect,
the people believe what they believe
because they're the ones who seem smart.
They're not the heretics,
they're the believers.
So you end up with a.
You start out just with a natural quest.
We want to know if the guidelines are
correct and through this completely
natural human process,
you end up staffing the guy creating a
committee that's going to recapitulate
the conventional wisdom almost 100
percent and it's just the way things
happen.
So you need people like me to come
across every once in a while,
assuming I can write better when the
people like me are right.
Then when they're wrong,
but you're going to get both types and
we got to come along.
We have to have the persistence,
you know,
that basically just keep doing what we
do.
I was lucky that I also had this podium,
the New York Times magazine editors
trusted me and liked my work.
The science editors trusted me and
thought I would be really good so I
could get an influential publications.
I didn't have to,
you know,
published to a blog and try to win
people over.
But from their perspective,
I mean it's just what do you do with
someone like me?
And I argued,
look,
I've done this research.
You haven't.
I mean,
another way to think about it,
I went,
I said,
look,
you know,
we've got these obesity and diabetes
epidemics worldwide.
I mean,
there should be horrifying to people.
Okay.
I'm in fairly recent.
Well,
in terms of human history,
so one of the game,
one of the things I did in the case
against sugar is I went back to find the
very beginnings of the epidemic in the
United States because if you got an
epidemic,
like if we had the Zika epidemic,
Ebola,
what do you do?
You're going to try to figure out what's
causing a bola by looking at the
patients who are getting off the
airplane and Houston are showing up in
the hospital in New Jersey.
You go back to Africa where it's densest
and where it started and you could
follow it to whatever animal got bit by
whatever insect and whatever cave and
that's a natural process of
understanding an epidemic.
So I go back here and you can go back to
the,
the 19th century and there are hospitals
in the United States,
the date to pre 18,
50 or 18,
64 in the case of Philadelphia Hospital
in Pennsylvania.
And that their records anyway,
go there and you can ask the archivist
to go back.
They still have their case records from
the 19th century and you can have the
archivist pull up the case records and
they will tell you how many cases of
diabetes were diagnosed in the
hospitals.
And you know,
any year from like in mass general
hospital in Boston.
The record starting in 18,
24,
um,
today,
one in 11 American diabetic.
Okay.
And there are some populations like
native American populations where one in
two adults are diabetic.
Jesus Christ in Boston,
mass general hospital,
that leading hospital in the country and
the,
in Massachusetts in the 19th century.
There were year after year after year
were hit,
they had zero cases of diabetes and this
was a terrible disease.
Without insulin,
it's not a pleasure with it,
but before insulin was discovered,
I mean you go blind,
kidney failure,
gangrene,
amputation.
So it's not a difficult diagnosis.
Now there are the reasons to explain the
absence.
I mean,
you know,
the only people showed up in hospitals
back in the 19th century were poor
people and poor people eat a lot less
sugar than rich people.
Wow.
So enrich people got their own private
doctor so they might not have shown up
in the diabetes in the medical record.
So you can,
you got to always be skeptical of what
you think you're learning because that's
what science is.
But you know,
the point I'm making is I went through
the effort to do this one way or the
other and that gives me a certain
advantage that they don't have.
And if they're good scientists,
regardless of what they believe,
they'll say to themselves,
Geez,
you know,
I never thought of this.
I never did that.
I can think of these tabs is wrong,
but maybe I should look into it.
And where did it all start?
So in the u s it starts again in the
second half of the 18 19th century and
it starts coincidentally with an
explosion and sugar consumption,
not just in how much sugar we're
consuming,
but who's consuming it,
which is what's fascinating and scary.
So prior go back,
say 200 years,
you know,
18,
10,
15,
we were probably getting about five
pounds of sugar per capita in the United
States.
So that's about five pounds over a
period of a year per person per year.
So that's the equivalent of,
about the sugar,
a one Coca Cola,
12 ounce cokes worth of sugar every six
days.
And it was the head of the hilarious.
It's not like it's frightening because
it's expensive back then,
right?
The attitude back then,
um,
you know,
they would,
well they desert courses hadn't really
been invented yet.
Really know.
I mean,
again,
the wealthy would have dessert,
so the wealthy and the wealthy are the
ones who would get diabetes and obesity
and gout back then.
Um,
so sugar has this curve where it goes
from being very rare and just sort of
the luxury of royalty to the wealthy are
using it.
And then finally with the beginning of
the industrial revolution and a late
18th century,
and then refining processes or improved
and sugar starts to get cheaper.
And then during the Napoleonic wars,
like 18,
12,
when France has cut from the,
from their sugar supply,
by the English blockades,
Napoleon says,
look,
we got to figure out how to create our
own sugar in this clever Frenchmen and
figures out how to get sugar from sugar
beets.
And the beet sugar industry takes off
around 1850.
Um,
and then with the beet sugar and street
and sugar in the northern hemisphere and
the temperate climates,
and you could also grow sugar cane and
it's only in tropical climates.
So now sugar prices started to plummet.
Meanwhile,
you think about all the ways we consume
sugar today.
So candy,
soft drinks,
ice cream,
chocolate.
The low fat desserts,
low fat milk,
low fat yogurt.
None of that existed until 1840.
So 1840.
Is He the start of the candy industry?
They started the chocolate industry,
the lint brothers and Switzerland figure
out how to make chocolate bars.
They're still,
you can still buy Lindt chocolate today
and it's pretty good actually.
Um,
ice cream industry starts in the 1840
[inaudible] soft drinks starting the 18
seventies with Dr Pepper than Coca Cola
than Pepsico.
Dr Pepper was first Dr.
Pepper was first.
Oh,
weird.
Yeah,
that's like an afterthought.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
Well,
I didn't have the marketing budgets of
the Coca Cola people.
Um,
so sugar starts becoming like women are
targeted as cold as you know,
because it's now cheap enough.
So the men get their alcohol and their
cigarettes and the women get sugar and
the kids get sugar.
So the first time in history,
suddenly we have all these industries
created to basically target children as
customers.
If you think about it,
nobody's drinking cold drinks at home.
So refrigeration,
refrigeration until the 19 thirties and
no vending machines until the 19
thirties.
I love this because I'm a science guy,
but in doing my books,
you have to become a historian and you
just don't think about this stuff.
So with the vending machines and the
refrigerators,
suddenly Coca Cola and Pepsico and these
start targeting,
you know,
you start getting a six packs and the
cartons,
cases of sodas and big bottles of soda
that you could take home,
put in your refrigerator and drink all
day long,
couldn't do it before that,
couldn't get ice cubes easily before
that you couldn't even,
you know,
quote down in the summer,
um,
fruit juices come in in the 19 thirties,
a California orange growers.
That's a big one,
right?
Because that's one of the people think
is totally innocuous and actually
healthy.
Yeah,
because it's got all that vitamin C,
which is explaining to people right now
that if you're drinking a big glass of
orange juice,
you might as well be drinking a pepsi
effectively.
That's what I believe.
So those are the two b.
You got these complete putting
nutritional paradigms.
One says if it's got vitamins and
minerals in a telephone,
it's a pepsi with vitamins and minerals.
It's a pepsi with vitamins and minerals,
take a vitamin pill and then drink a
pepsi and it's the same goddamn
effectively.
Yeah,
it's so crazy to me.
I always thought like,
what's fresh squeezed?
It's got Paul Pinot.
Well,
this is when.
So the California Orange Growers Forum
sunkist that was a consortium of
California.
They had all these extra oranges,
they couldn't sell at oranges are all
come and you coming along in one season.
So back then without refrigeration and
cars,
he could keep fruits kind of alive for
like a year.
By freezing them,
you know,
you had all these extra oranges you
couldn't sell.
So they said let's get people to turn
into orange juice and we'll advertise at
the vitamin C is good for the new
nutrition of the 19 twenties in 1930.
It was all about vitamin deficiency
diseases and so scurvy is caused by the
absence of vitamin C and Barry Barry by
vitamin B and that,
that was the big news.
So the orange growers started pushing
orange juice sawdust because it with
vitamin C content.
So now we're drinking fruit juices for
breakfast everyday and then post World
War Two concentrates are created.
That was actually a defense,
you know,
World War II program to try and figure
out how to create foods that soldiers
could take into battle and get their
vitamins from it.
So that comes along.
And then the last one is sugary cereals.
So the scenario in the street was
created by um,
compost and Kellogg who are health nuts.
They ran sanatoriums and Minnesota,
right?
And they knew their health nutritionist
didn't want to put sugar in anything.
They had some huge fights over this.
Um,
but 19,
48 post release sugar crisps some.
And it's,
you know,
30 percent sugar by calories or
something.
That's the first sugar coated cereal.
And for the next decade you can watch
the cereal industries have these
internal battles where the marketing
people are saying,
we need a sugar sweetened cereal.
We've got to compete.
We're going to be run out of the
business.
And the health people are saying,
no,
no sugar is bad for you.
And in every case,
the marketers one by the 19 sixties,
not only do you have like all these,
some of these scenarios were 50 percent
sugar by calories,
still are,
but you've got all these iconic TV shows
that were created just to sell sugar
cereals too.
I mean rocky and bullwinkle,
which is my favorite.
This was heartbreaking.
I mean those guys were created to sell
cereal to the women,
the comic,
the TV show that was created as a
vehicle to market.
I forget which cereal it was which
company,
but all of these things,
you know,
I mean there were,
the cartoon was an afterthought.
The cartoon was a method to sell.
So the,
the cereal industry would hire,
you know,
these brilliant public relations men who
would create these characters and then
get Hollywood to create animated tv
shows with these characters.
And then they would always sell the same
sugar sweetened cereals.
Wow.
And so now we're just,
you know,
think what happened to kids.
Okay.
So the obese and diabetic people in the
world are the ones who started.
We all started as children,
right?
So you know,
18,
oh five,
10,
updating 50,
maybe they see sugar once a week,
you know,
they still went to the country store and
when Uncle Ed is turned the wrong way,
they stick their hand in the sugar
barrow and lick their fingers and alc by
1960.
It's like orange juice cereal,
you know,
sugary cereal,
sugar on the sugary cereal for
breakfast,
you know,
a coke for a snack and candy bar.
The same kind of foods for lunch.
I mean,
I bet most Americans didn't go more than
three hours without a sugar dose,
whereas 150 years earlier they'd had
gone a week between doses.
And as this happens,
you see these explosions and obesity and
diabetes that they're slow to build and
I think I could eat that can be
explained to by the fact that mothers
pass this on to their kids when the kids
are in the wound.
Is there a difference in how much of a
difference is there,
if any between,
um,
diet,
dietary diabetes or diet diabetes is
directly attributed to diet and genetic?
Well,
again,
there are different.
First of all,
there are different types,
type one diabetes type one type one is
the acute form that hits mostly in
childhood,
um,
and has a strong genetic component.
It's an auto immune disease,
but that doesn't mean it's not
fundamentally caused by sugar.
And by that I mean if we didn't never
get around to eating sugar,
we wouldn't have type one diabetes and
that really woke people that think that
type one diabetes,
which is something that um,
people I know have and well,
it's just genetic.
It's just something you were born with.
That's not necessarily true.
Oh,
they couldn't be born with it.
I mean,
it could be an,
it could be genetic,
but it still has to be triggered,
could be triggered by something in the
environment.
So these people with type one diabetes
didn't have a poor diet,
didn't consume sugar,
didn't eat the average American diet
would never itself their mothers.
Maybe even more importantly in the womb,
in the womb.
Yeah,
Christ.
The third to last chapter of my book,
the lead to,
of the last three chapters before the
epilogue is called are called the if
then problems.
So let me lay out what I'm proposing
here.
The case against sugar.
Here's the.
So the.
There's a crime,
I think of it as a,
you know,
we're in a courtroom,
a courtroom and there's a crime that's
committed.
The crime is epidemics of obesity and
diabetes that happened whenever a
population transitions from their
traditional diet to a western diet and
lifestyle.
So it doesn't matter what the population
is,
it can be the inuits living on like
Caribou and cme.
They could be Mussai living on the
blood,
milk,
meat from the cattle they heard.
That could be agrarian populations,
that could be south Pacific islanders
living on coconuts.
And you know,
pigs.
I'm aborigines in Australia,
Middle Eastern populations,
African populations,
European populations.
It does not matter.
Eventually they transition.
You see these epidemics of recent
diabetes,
that's the crime.
So the argument I'm making is that sugar
is always at the scene of the crime in a
population wide level.
So there's a lot of things that happen
when you transitioned to western diets.
For instance,
a lot of populations eat more meat,
but some populations like the inuits,
they don't eat more me because they
reading or the native Americans of the
plains Indians,
they don't eat more meat because they
were living on me to begin with,
but they also get obesity and diabetes
epidemics.
I'm willing to rule out meat on that
level and other people did as well.
You know,
they become more sedentary when you're
Westernized.
You get more labor saving devices,
you dry places instead of walking
places.
So maybe it's sedentary behavior,
but you could find populations that are
incredibly physically active.
Um,
cane cut it there a in the natal region
of South Africa in the 18th century,
they used to import a in the Indians
from India as indentured slaves,
indentured laborers effectively slavery,
but they call them indentured laborers
to work in the sugar plantations and a
cane cutters in the sugar plantations.
That was one of the most energy intense
jobs you can imagine than one estimate
was they burned 9,000
calories a day.
And yet,
these in the town Indians had among the
highest rates of diabetes ever seen and
their ancestors,
the population from which they were
drawn in India,
had virtually no diabetes and the
primary difference in their diet was a
sugar consumption.
So you could play this game where you
isolate out populations and what you
find.
What I found,
this is no population when you get an
obesity and diabetes epidemic,
where sugar recent increases in sugar
consumption habit occurred and by recent
it could be 20 years ago,
could be 50 years ago.
So it's always at the scene of the
crime.
Now,
type two diabetes,
the common form that associates with
excess weight is a,
um,
uh,
it's fundamentally the sort of what's
called insulin resistance.
So type one,
you,
your pancreas doesn't secrete enough
insulin.
Type two,
your body is resistant to the insulin
that your pancreas secretes.
So you gotTa pump,
you've got to secrete more and more to
keep your blood sugar under control.
And the idea is eventually your pancreas
gets exhausted and the can't do it
anymore.
And then you have a deficit of insulin
and it looks like you're.
The results were pretty much similar to
type one.
So insulin resistance is also very
closely associated to obesity.
And we could discuss that as well.
Um,
you could look at these epidemics of
obesity,
diabetes,
heart disease,
cancer,
Alzheimer's,
dementia basically is manifestations of
insulin resistance happening all around
the world in different ways and
different people,
but they're all related to insulin
resistance and insulin.
And then you ask yourself,
well causes the insulin resistance.
So the best researchers in the world who
study insulin resistance,
the leading hypothesis is that it starts
in the liver and it starts in the liver
with the conversion,
with the accumulation of fats and liver
cells.
And in fact,
we also have an epidemic of what's
called nonalcoholic fatty liver disease
in this country right now used to be 20
slash 30 years ago,
if I'm.
If you've got fatty liver disease and
you saw your doctor and you told them
you didn't drink,
they would just assume you're lying
because they clearly.
Alcoholics got fatty liver disease.
But suddenly people started showing up
who swore they didn't drink,
and then kids started showing up with
fatty liver disease who clearly didn't
drink alcohol.
So we got this concept nonalcoholic
fatty liver disease.
It's basically indistinguishable from
the alcoholic kind and it's happened.
The CDC estimates 40 million Americans
have this,
and if it progresses,
it can progress to what's called Nash,
which is not alcoholics stereo
hepatitis,
and eventually the need for liver
transplant.
So Sugar Christ.
Now I know like what are we talking
about when we're talking about sugar?
So sugar cane sugar beet sugar are
technically sucrose.
That's a molecule of glucose bonded to a
molecule.
Fructose,
fructose makes it sweet.
High Fructose Corn Syrup is 45 percent
glucose,
55 percent fructose,
same chemical constituents.
They're not bonded together.
I don't think that makes a damn bit of
difference.
Some people do.
Um,
the fructose is metabolized in your
liver,
so the glucose gets into your
bloodstream,
just like any other glucose from any
other carbohydrate.
The fructose goes to your liver and your
liver gets it in a high dose,
like say from an apple juice or
something.
It has trouble dealing with that much
fructose.
You never evolved to see a glass of
apple juice for glass can of cokes worth
of fructose be delivered over the course
of five,
10 minutes,
probably even 30 minutes,
so it converted into fat.
So we have a condition,
insulin resistant that's epidemic
worldwide that you know,
the leading research in the country
think is caused by the accumulation of
fat in liver cells and we've got a
substance sugar that's been exploded in
use worldwide in which half of it is
metabolized in the liver and it's
converted into fat and liver cells.
So it's like it's at the scene of the
crime in populations and set the scene
of the crime in a body and it's got a
mechanism.
It's got the gun necessary.
You know,
you can match the bullets almost,
but we don't have the smoking gun.
That's where the research falls short.
And then,
so this is the case I'm making.
Then if sugar causes insulin resistance,
there are all kinds of downstream
effects including what mothers will do
to their children if they are insulin
resistant and have high blood sugar when
they're pregnant.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's why my argument is,
you know,
it's almost too much.
It would be easier if I just said it's
empty calories because you know what,
what back against your book and against
your research,
have you experienced.
Well,
I mean,
there are people who just object to my
exists.
Have you debated these people?
Uh,
I'm in the process of debating to have
them online now.
The keto in Keto,
one bound,
it's called.
I went to,
by the way,
done this.
If I'm,
I'm not a fan of debates in science
because I don't think they settled
thing.
I'm a fans of people getting together
and saying,
look,
you believe this,
I believe this.
What experiment can we do to find out
who's not,
who's the better rider?
You know,
read a rhetorician I know what you're
saying.
Yeah.
He was more charismatic point across
more,
you know,
it's just that pallet in the obesity
society.
And the,
uh,
Jordan,
the nutrition society's once a year
they'll have their annual conference
alva debate over this and everybody,
Oh yeah,
I thought you did better,
but nobody walks out of the debate
saying,
what experiment can we do to settle
this?
And I think it's,
you don't get me to have these epidemics
are tragic.
The cost of obesity and diabetes in the
US direct cost,
the medical systems estimate is
$2,000,000,000
a year.
I mean,
excuse me,
a billion dollars a day.
What light direct cost to the healthcare
system.
Three hundred $65 million dollars a year
just because of obesity and diabetes.
Jesus.
And if you think about it,
so that's $365,000,000,000.
It is a direct cost to the tax burden on
the healthcare system,
but it's a tremendous for the
pharmaceutical industry,
right?
In the physicians and the hospitals that
are getting that money.
So they don't have quite much motivation
as might to stem this tide because
they're profiting
from it.
Are they even aware of the causes of it?
If your,
if your work is so controversial and
there's so many people out there that
are disputing it or disputing this link
between sugar and all these horrible
diseases and they're calling it empty
calories,
is this even something that in the
medical community where they spend a
ridiculously short amount of time in
school learning about nutrition and.
Well,
thank God for that because if they learn
more,
they would learn the wrong thing.
Right?
Then they'd be dogmatic point now.
Well these people,
they don't really have the information.
You know,
you can go ahead and blow your nose,
man.
Don't worry about it.
You've been struggling with it for
awhile.
He had gary sick because he hasn't had
enough sugar,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yes,
exactly.
Um,
but I mean,
it seems to me like they don't have the
time.
I mean,
I don't have the time to do the research
that you did.
A very few people do.
It really takes someone like you.
It takes a maniac to go out there and,
and stretch your finances and put
yourself in a bad position to and really
be obsessive chasing this down.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
Again,
that doesn't mean that you're supposed
to believe somebody like me.
And again,
you can,
you know,
I'm a journalist.
I used to think,
you know,
imagined some plumber came up to me one
day and he said,
you know,
I just spent like the last 10 years of
my life studying how to do termism and
I've written this book and you're doing
it all wrong.
That's a good point.
You know,
and I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
sure,
I'll take the book,
you know,
and I can't wait to read it.
Then I'm going to go home and I'm not
probably going to throw the book out
because the odds that that's a waste of
time for me are enormous.
When one was the first one,
when did diabetes first sort of emerge
in,
in medical records?
Medical records,
you said
2000 years ago when,
like Hindu medical documents,
uh,
coincidentally with the beginning of the
sugar industry in northern India.
Yeah,
I mean just give or take 200 years.
Holy Shit.
But,
um,
and even back then they speculate that
it was caused by sugar.
Although I think for the wrong reasons,
because the diabetic urine and you're
pissing out a lot of glucose,
right,
because your body can't handle it,
so it's Sweden,
it'll attract flies and back then even
up until a 17th century,
part of classic medical practice was for
the physician to have his assistant
taste the urine.
He didn't.
He didn't have to do it himself,
but the.
And that could be,
by the way,
one reason why a lot of diabetes went
undiagnosed.
People wouldn't drink the as people
wouldn't drink the pis.
Yeah.
So,
and you got to keep all this stuff in
mind.
I mean this is a ridiculous way.
All they had,
you know,
science is determined by the technology
available.
That was one of the lessons that we can
get into this because all my books are
about good science and bad science that
I.
I hope I understand what I'm doing.
Like I said,
I
know if I don't,
it's really bad.
It's embarrassing.
Yeah.
I wake up at three,
four in the morning and thinking,
why do I so obsessed about this calorie
issue?
Nobody else seems to care,
but people do now,
don't,
don't you feel that we live in a very
small world.
You know,
it's hard to understand.
I mean even with your whatever,
20 million downloads a month that all
your followers is not more than that.
Yeah.
I mean think about how many of those
voted for the current president for
instance.
I mean it's just,
it's a very.
I'm glad to hear it's a lot more because
I want to get this out,
you know,
I mean even if it's just for this one
particular subject,
which I think is probably the most
important subject today when in terms of
health and wellness and just optimizing
your existence,
cutting out sugar and changing your diet
I think is one of the most important
factors and living a healthier,
more productive life and also mental
clarity.
Well now let me ask you a question.
When you cut out sugar,
so you said you cut it out slowly.
What were you eating at the time?
Because I gather I'd never ate bad.
The but I pastas and bread I eat.
I always supplemented with vitamins.
I always worked out hard and I was
always lean because I worked out so
much,
so I never thought I had an issue with
fat or I never thought I had an issue
with any of those things,
but I would get that crash.
I would did that in late afternoon crash
and this fucking insulin dump.
Yeah,
I used to say,
I say I don't take naps.
They take me like an hour after lunch
and I'd be interviewing some Nobel
prize.
What I'd have to think of an excuse to
get off because I was falling asleep.
Do you mean that doesn't happen to me
anymore?
No,
it's fascinating.
It's unbelievably fascinating.
I would never have guessed.
I would've thought you needed some sort
of stimulant to keep you going like
that.
Although in all honesty,
we were both drinking bulletproof
coffees right now,
so we are getting some sort of
stimulant.
We are,
but I didn't.
I didn't have to have that.
I mean,
but that's the book tour.
Yeah,
but here's the thing,
when you cut out the grains,
the bread,
the pasta,
that's still.
That's glucose.
So were you eating sugar?
We're drinking gatorade very rarely,
very rarely.
I was still eating pretty clean,
like I would have dessert every now and
then,
but it wasn't more than a few times a
week.
I wasn't eating candy bars during the
day,
but I was eating the occasional protein
bar that was loaded with sugar that I
didn't even think it was.
So that's what I thought it was.
Eating healthy.
That's what gets me.
So once we got into this diet,
to this idea.
So one of the things,
and this was a second article I read,
so is there evidence to support this
idea we should be eating the low fat
diet?
I mean the second article I wrote and I
recreated the history of that and it was
fascinating because once these people
got this idea that fat caused heart
disease.
So remember,
science is determined by what you can
measure.
So the technology have tells you what
you can measure and what you can
measure,
what you can ask questions about,
and then that gives you the answers and
if you're bad scientists forget that.
It's completely limited to the
technology.
So there's an old joke in science
called the drunk and the streetlight
problem,
do you ever hear about now?
So guys walking down the street and he
comes upon a drawn coups crawling around
in his knees under a street light and he
says to the guy,
what are you doing?
And the guy says,
I'm looking for my keys.
And the guy said,
so cisco,
you lost them in the drunk goes,
I don't know where I lost them,
but this is where the light is.
Okay.
So in science it's like what you could
measure is where the light is and you
got to remember that there's a universe
out there that you can't see yet
because.
But most scientists,
most scientists don't realize that
they're just not good scientists.
So in the heart disease,
the light was on cholesterol.
That was at 1950 sixties.
That's what they could measure.
And they got this idea that it's caused
by dietary fat.
And because of that we just,
you know,
again,
they tested and tested this hypothesis
and kept being failed the test,
but they didn't care because they
thought it had to be true.
And by the 19 eighties we lock it in as
a dogma and now we have this idea that
the healthy way to eat is a low fat diet
and you start making products where you
take the fat out of it and once you take
the fat out of something,
it doesn't taste all that good.
Like yogurts,
a classic example,
I mean it is fat and some modest amount
of black posts.
I don't even know if there's lactose in
it and I should know this stuff because
then people say clearly you're not a
nutritionist,
so they candy bars instead of eating
snickers bars,
which a high fat,
high sugar thing that we grew up on.
You create clif bars and nature's way
bars and all these low fat health food
bars that we think are healthy because
they're low in fat.
They're loaded with carbs and they fill
them up with sugar.
And then to this day I'm wondering like,
should I just let you know,
we have a drawer with these health food
bars at my wife.
I'm not the only parent in the family.
So my kids are in tortured by my food
beliefs.
Um,
would they be healthier if they just ate
snickers bars like we did when we were
kids?
And I don't know what the answer is.
I literally,
I could argue it either way.
How could you argue it?
That they would be healthier if they had
all that sugar?
Well,
they both have the sugar.
Will you both like Lara bars versus
those Lara bars?
I really love those.
They taste good,
but they're 19 fucking grams of sugar or
something crazy.
And it's only like the size of your
thumb.
Yeah.
So the basically,
I don't know what the sugar content that
you can probably google it while we're
talking about regular size snickers bar.
It's probably more than 19 grams,
but it's also got all that fat in it,
which will slow down the digestion of
the sugar.
So a snickers bar arguably is better for
you than some of these really super
sugary,
what we think air quotes are healthy
snacks like trail bars and.
Yeah,
and the key word there is arguably it.
Here we go,
20 grams of sugar.
And what does that.
A snickers bar.
That's a lot.
Yes.
Christ.
Yeah.
But it's a bigger.
It's going to be a big way more.
So what about the law of in a way more.
Well,
it's a 44 grams.
Okay.
Yeah.
Those things.
Lara bars.
St.
Find out what,
what the fuck is in those bad boys?
Because I had one.
I bought one once.
This is before I had gone on my crusade
sugar.
It says wait a minute.
But they're fruit and nut bars.
So the question is how much sugar are in
the fruit?
Maybe you're looking at the.
Maybe it's a different one.
Which one are you looking at here?
Yeah,
that's it.
What does it say here?
How many grams?
Twenty grams.
So it's the same as this.
So why the fuck are they lying?
No added sugar.
It could be because it comes from fruit
sugar.
Your body doesn't know that you're
playing a Goddamn game.
Yes.
You're playing a game.
Exactly.
Let's say.
I'm just curious how fruits and nuts in
their bars.
World Health Organization's recommended
daily sugar intake for adults.
Five percent of daily caloric intake for
normal weight adult eating 2000 calories
a day.
That's 25 grams.
So now is that added sugar per day?
I mean when you're talking about
lactose,
when you talk to me about fruits,
it's funny,
I just,
a friend just sent me an article today
on a European Journal of clinical
nutrition where they were looking at
sugar content of children's diets in
Europe and they age one,
they were 30 percent of their calories
from sugar Jesus Christ,
but just trying to make sense of it.
I pretty sure that included lactose free
milk,
which was a primary source.
He said the primary source of the sugar
with dairy products.
It could also be from,
you know,
a Bot artificial formulas.
People take that in consideration,
right?
If you two pieces of cheese,
you're getting some sugar.
Yeah.
Although again,
cheese once you process it,
process and lose the lactose.
Um,
but yeah,
it sort of.
But even the lactose is metabolized
differently than the fructose.
So I would argue that we evolved to
consume lactose at least until we were
out in weaning.
Few,
three,
four years old.
Drank milk,
no,
I actually gave up their right,
but for different reasons,
not because I uh,
for me it has unfortunate
gastrointestinal side effects that my
whole family could live without,
um,
you know,
uh,
if you go into a low carb,
high fat diet,
which I think is a help,
certainly those of us should be eating
or predisposed to get fat or diabetic.
Um,
yeah.
Cheese is a very valuable item with the
Diet and clearly like the French and the
Swiss and even the Greeks had enormous
amounts of cheese and they live quite a
long time there.
Do you believe in raw milk?
Have you attempted to try that?
Or raw cheese?
I don't.
Is My gut feeling from him or I'm a,
I'm a,
I focus obsessively on one subject and
it's the carb content and the sugars and
the refined grains and the.
What's the cause of obesity?
I don't.
Raw milk doesn't enter into that
discussion.
And what Amanda about it is just from
the gastrointestinal issues,
because a lot of people believe that raw
milk with all the natural enzymes in it
is easier for your body to process.
That's quite possible,
but again,
as a,
if you're way weight easily,
then I wouldn't be recommending liquid
carbs of any kind,
including the lactose.
And so,
um,
they look at the low carb diets
traditionally and historically they
never allowed for milk even.
I mean,
you might go for a heavy cream or cream,
you know,
that sort of Atkins thing or the
bulletproof coffee thing.
But yeah,
I know a lot of people who are on the
key to genic diet that will actually
drink heavy cream.
Yeah.
My friend Kyle,
who actually was one of the first people
that turned me onto at Kingsbury,
he,
uh,
he carries around this little fucking
pint of heavy cream,
but he's a savage.
Yeah,
no,
my uh,
former collaborator Peter Attia who's
his,
you know,
Internet handle.
One point I think was kidogenic man and
he used to drink olive oil cheeses,
cream a well because you've got to
really up the fat those diets for a lot
of people to get Cathartic.
Not everyone,
but um,
it's interesting.
I thought I heard you were trying it.
I'm on it.
Yeah.
And what essentially.
So tell me your diet.
Well,
um,
a lot of Avocados,
a lot of coconut oil.
I'm,
I might eat a little bit more protein
than I'm supposed to,
which unfortunately does convert back to
sugar in your body of glucose,
but easily much more easily processed
obviously than high fructose corn syrup.
Right.
I'm very,
very little pastas or grains or breads
or anything.
It's a rare thing that I eat that stuff.
Do you actually measure your ketones?
I've done it before,
but I have a problem with those things.
Those,
the Jab,
your finger.
It's too hard for me to get blood out.
I do a lot of Kettlebell stuff,
houses on my fingers and my hands,
so I have to actually go into the side
of my hand to get the blood I have to go
like above the fingerprints to the upper
skin area and squeeze out the blood.
It's fucking annoying.
So I know when I'm in it.
And also I take um,
ketogenic supplements.
I'll take like a exoticness ketones.
Like there's this stuff called regenix.
Is there anything that tastes decent?
Yeah.
Key genex tastes really good,
tastes good.
It's a good drink.
It's a,
it's made by Dom D'agostino is one of
the premier research scientists that's
devoted to a ketogenic diet and I heard
about him from Tim Ferriss,
his podcast,
and I've read some of his work online
and listened to some of his lectures and
talks and um,
I find it a,
first of all,
as far as like appetite suppressing.
It's fantastic once your body starts
burning fat,
you don't get that weird hunger thing.
Was it?
Yeah.
That's the thing because you're not just
mobilizing your fat,
burning it,
it's all coming out.
It's not being your bodies and trying to
hold onto it.
You're not freaking out.
That's the thing.
It's like when I was on a heavy carb
diet,
because I love pasta.
Got It.
Love like Lasagna and linguine with
clams
and it's just like.
I just love it.
It's fantastic and occasionally on
indulge as a rare treat now,
but when I was eating it all the time,
I would have this two or three hour post
eating thing where that stuff would be
gone.
It would all be digested and then I'd be
fucking starving in the next hour or so.
I remember the old joke about,
you know Chinese like two hours later,
you're starving.
Yeah,
I mean that's really what it is.
Your body starts craving those
carbohydrates as simple car
because you're.
You're.
You're burning the sugar so you.
The carbs are converted to glucose.
You're burning the glucose,
you're secreting insulin,
and the insulin is telling you fat to
hold onto fat.
This is my theory anyway,
and it's backed up by the evidence,
so as the blood sugar starts coming
down,
your fat tissue is supposed to release
the fat and allow to come out and be
oxidized by the same cells and the
Mitochondria in your cells and this
famous krebs cycle that we're all
supposed to learn in like 11th grade
biology and could never remember.
The Krebs cycle is just as happy to burn
fat as Carbs,
but if the insulin's high,
it's telling your Mitochondria to burn
carbs,
not fat,
and it's telling the fat cells to hold
onto fat and now you've just got a
dearth of fuel.
It's actually telling your lean tissue
to hold onto protein,
so now your blood sugar's coming down,
but the insulin still elevated and
there's no fuels replacing the blood
sugar and now you bonk,
you bonk or you start to panic or you
know,
and this is why you know,
I mean,
once we instituted this low fat thing
and people said,
well,
Americans get fat because they snack all
the time.
They're constantly grazing where they're
constantly grazing because their cells
are running out of fuel.
No matter how much they're eating for
breakfast of their low fat stuff,
if they're insulin is elevated,
their cells are gonna,
wanna burn carbs.
And this is one of the observations you
found in the literature in the 1830
[inaudible].
There was a Hungarian endocrinologist
working at northwestern university.
You talked about some of his obese pay.
He said he had a patient who was an
obese Alondra's fused to eat laundry
starch.
Oh Jesus Christ.
But that's what the fuck is.
Laundry starch starch.
It's a carbohydrate,
man.
I didn't.
I had no idea.
But the point is,
if your insulin is elevated,
carbohydrates are your fuel.
It's singling your cells to burn glucose
and not to burn fat and not the burn
protein,
so carbs are your fuel there young.
That's what you need,
so when you start to get hungry,
you crave that because that's the only
thing your cells are going to burn.
So then if you do like you try a get
agentic diet or low carb,
high fat diet,
whatever you wanna call it and you get
rid of the carbs and you get an effect,
your insulin comes down.
Then you get this natural thing where
you eat your store.
Some of the fat,
you're burning fat.
When you're done burning the fat in your
bloodstream,
the fat comes out of yourselves.
There's just nice cycle that's supposed
to happen.
You always have enough fuel available
that you know you're not hungry.
That's one of the common phenomenon.
It's the idea that suddenly I have
breakfast.
The next thing I know it's two,
three in the afternoon and I'm thinking
maybe I should eat lunch just because I
should eat lunch because I'm hungry.
Knox,
I'm starving.
You know,
and they need lunch.
He'll fall asleep afterwards because
your body has a fuel supply because your
body has a concept fullest by yourselves
or being fueled whether you're reading
or not.
You got an a fat in your body to live
for like a month even if you're
relatively leave.
No,
I should point out that some high level
athletes are having an issue with this.
Some people that are used to burning off
massive amounts cowers during the day,
like mixed martial artists and things
along those lines.
Some of them adapt to it fine and I
haven't had a great time with it and
find it easier to make weight and easier
to train,
but other ones say that they have just a
lack of that extra gear and training.
Now.
I don't know if they're doing it fully
disciplined,
like if they're monitoring their
ketones.
If they're really sure about their diet,
they've got it 75 slash 25.
Some of the earliest studies ever done
on this was by a guy named Steve Finney,
who's co author of two books,
the art and science of low carb living
in the art and science of low carb
performance and Steve Back in the late
seventies,
early eighties.
He was at the,
I think it's Vermont,
where there was a team of people
studying doing some interesting diet
experiments and he put professional bike
racers and ketogenic diets and measured
their performance versus their sort of
traditional high carb diets and he keto
adapted them so they were fully adapted
to burning fat for fuel and from his
studies basically he said that they're
more efficient until they have to push
that last sort of five percent out like
up a mountain marathon or getting to
heartbreak hill and the Boston marathon
and then they lose that extra push.
See,
that's what makes sense because that
extra push is all what mixed martial
arts is about.
Yeah.
That extra push is all about.
I mean in mma it's all about exploding
when you're tired.
It's all about being able to manage your
endurance over the course of five
minutes,
but figuring out these sprint times and
being able to squeeze the most out of
those two.
Break your opponent.
Yeah.
It's a lot of times it's based on how
much you have in the tank.
Yeah,
well that's the thing and I mean a lot
of it you should still.
You can still,
even though it's funny,
carb loading when it was first a sort of
perfected was the developed in
Scandinavia by.
I'm in back in the fifties,
I think it was by the coaches have cross
country skiers,
which is an incredibly like physically a
burden,
some brutal,
brutal,
so.
And they trained all year long on low
carb diets so they would train on low
carb diets and the idea was they would
eat the plate of pasta,
you know,
the race and they would maximize their
glycogen stores and they're living in
their cells and then when they needed
it,
it was there.
And is that have been proven efficient?
Eh?
I mean it was a great way for them,
but then it was.
But again,
the point is at reading the low carb
diets,
the until the year and then once
marathoner started doing everyone
thought with marathon and she'd eat
carbs the night before a marathon,
we should always eat carbs.
And then this idea that carpenter
heart-healthy came in and they just took
over the world.
So,
but my area of expertise is by no means
like high performance athletes.
There are people out there who could
talk to you for,
you know,
and I'll recommend some when we get off.
Um,
but you know,
it's interesting because even when you
read the debates about this stuff,
what the high performance athletes,
I see this and like outside magazine and
runner's world stuff.
So there's this fundamental argument
that,
look,
we don't get facts.
We too much.
We get fat because of carbohydrates in
our diet causes hormonal metabolic
dysregulation that makes us store
calories of fat and our fat cells.
And that implies that the healthiest
diet for those of us who get fat or
diets absent,
you know,
easily digestible carbs and sugars.
But if athletes,
very high performing athletes eat those
diets and don't perform better than
before,
it's not a good diet and therefore all
the rest of it is wrong and that's just
crazy.
You know,
it's sort of what Lance Armstrong needs
to win the Tour de France,
whatever it is,
doesn't tell me a hell of a lot about
why,
you know,
Shirley Maclaine talk weighs 300 pounds
and can't lose that weight unless she
gives up carbohydrates,
you know,
and all of that gets confounded in these
discussions.
And one of the things I'm constantly
doing when I talk about this stuff
saying you got to keep your eye on a
question because we were all given
different answers to different
questions.
So what's the best diet for winning the
Tour de France or mma fight probably got
a lot of the same themes that I'm
talking about.
But even then funny when sugar came in
beginning around the 18 nineties and it
was a cheap and easily available and
beach hooker was available element
Germany.
The German army started testing sugar as
a performance enhancer and actually
doing sort of trials where they would
send troops out with or without sugar
for,
you know,
30 day marches,
and then they would see when they came
back,
which ones had more energy and the ones
who ate more sugar had more energy and
they,
a mountain climbers started using it.
Um,
crew coach has started testing it on the
crew,
like rowing back then was a,
among the most popular sports in the
world.
And so they would give their rowers a
sugar and see if they perform better,
which they inevitably did.
It was a great performance enhancing
drug.
It's a psychoactive drug.
It kills pain.
It is,
you know,
the joke.
It's quick energy.
Sugar kills pain.
Yeah.
It's why we give it the kids,
you know,
if your baby was he circumcised.
I've girls then okay.
Not an issue.
Boys circumcise them.
Give them a little bit of sugar.
You never heard of that though?
But yeah,
it's a distraction.
It's a pain killer.
I mean,
it's a wonderful psychoactive
properties.
No short term side effects.
You know,
me and me,
you're talking about must be talking
about a very minor if you also,
if you start with populations that never
consumed sugar,
babies never consumed it before you
came.
A little sugar,
like on day three you can circumcise
them and then they're just tripping.
They're fine.
Hey,
cool.
I'll take it off.
I don't need to live with what,
what am I gonna use that for.
I mean,
when you know,
you're three days old,
you got no imagination.
Wow.
We could talk about um,
the uh,
yeah.
So anyway,
that's the thing,
I,
it's that it could be a performance
enhancing drug
that would enhance the performance of
athletes at the highest level.
Doesn't mean it doesn't have longterm
chronic affects,
just like any other performance
enhancing drug.
So there's a big difference between
people that are like say climbing k two
that need something to push them forward
versus the average person who likes to
play Racquetball and works a day job and
you know,
and that kind of a diet and think about,
I mean the athletic trainers who have
been telling you,
I mean the guys you work out with your
whole,
you know,
the lean muscular guys who never had an
ounce of fat in their lives and they're
saying we should all wheat carbs that we
should always sugar because I look how
well I process it.
And my argument is like,
if you think your body works the same
way as your cousin who weighs 300 pounds
and the only differences you exercise
more like that's a serious delusion.
And you know,
we're different people.
I don't know.
You have siblings?
Yes.
Are you all built in like a sister?
I mean,
she's mean she's,
I mean she,
she works out a little bit.
Not,
not like I do,
but you know,
we have good genes in that regard.
But I mean,
when I was a kid,
my older brother,
a mathematician,
brilliant guy,
but he was always taller,
leaner,
like you could see the veins on his arms
and the ripples on his stomach just
seven years old by a lot by.
It wasn't genetic because I clearly had
the same gene to different body types.
But they vary,
right?
Yeah.
So when he got to college,
he was a rower.
He couldn't get over one 95 no matter
how much he ate.
And he used to say
never forget this,
I'll never get stuffed or just get bored
of eating after a few hours.
And I was shorter,
thicker,
you know,
I put on weight relatively easily.
By the time I was in high school,
I weighed one 95 when I was playing
division two,
college football,
I could get up to 2:37
and no matter how much I ate,
I could not get above 2:37
and I was three inches shorter than he
was.
We just had different body types.
We,
I've built muscle easier than he did.
And I put on fat easier than he did.
It had nothing to with how much we both
ate as much as we could in fact dinners
in our family.
I like 18 minutes because it was,
you know,
my mother was put down like you know,
enough for,
for eight people and if I didn't trust
my brother,
yeah,
exactly.
Started seven over seven,
18,
no matter what she served.
When you're looking at all this data and
you're putting together this book and
you realize that you're going to drop
this mindblower on people that we're,
we've been essentially misled by almost
every established organization when it
comes to health and diet.
How are you feeling when you're about to
release it?
So you has a 10.
Is this one thing we like?
Jesus Christ?
Am I just do?
I mean,
did you have this like incredible desire
to like double check,
triple check,
quadruple check?
No,
but I should have the um.
Okay.
So the first time this happened,
so the articles in science for whatever
we're using then create all that much
controversy.
I mean,
they won awards and reporting awards and
know they were in books about the best
science writing,
but nobody really cared.
I mean there was enough controversy
about whether this low fat diet for
instance,
was the right thing that I do.
This New York Times magazine article
where,
you know,
the idea was to go out and find out that
this was pitched in 2001 and the,
our awareness of the obesity epidemic
was only about three years old and you
could pinpoint it in time from between
the late 19 seventies to the early 19
nineties,
two surveys that were done.
And during those two surveys,
the prevalence of obesity almost almost
doubled.
United States,
the percentage of Americans.
So you'd asked the question what caused
it?
And I have two hypotheses.
One was we had shifted the 19 sixties,
that conventional wisdom was that
carbohydrates are uniquely fattening.
Like one our line,
I quote and two of my books was the
first sentence of a British journal of
Nutrition Article Nineteen Sixty three
written by one of the two leading
British Dietitians was every woman knows
carbohydrates are fattening and every
woman knew this car,
you know,
bread,
pasta,
potatoes,
rice,
beer,
sweets,
you know,
they'd go right to your hips.
That was a.
and then we turned them into a heart
healthy diet foods by the 19 eighties
and that happened between was
institutionalized between 1977 and 1984
and [inaudible] 84 like the New York
Times health reporters writing or Beth
selling diet health cooking book called
the Good Food Book.
And she's saying,
yeah,
we used to think carbs are fattening,
but now we should eat pasta and bread
all the time.
So that was one hypothesis.
The other was high fructose corn syrup,
which came in in 1977 and had sort of
replaced sugar and Pepsi and coke by
1984.
Anyways,
I'm doing that piece.
I realized I find stumbled upon five
studies of the Atkins Diet.
So the Atkins Diet is the scientists
call the anomalous observation.
So when you're always looking for in
sciences,
the anomalous observation,
that's the thing that doesn't fit with
any of your beliefs,
you know,
you've got a theory that says this,
and then you find that and,
and now you've got a way to come up with
a better theory because you got
something else,
you have to explain that you're present
theory doesn't and it's the anomalous
observations that move science forward.
It's the thing that just doesn't fit
with your belief.
So here's the Diet trials where he got
the atkins diet high in fat,
high in saturated fat.
So she'll give you heart disease,
you know,
double quarter pounder with cheese,
no bun,
lobster Newberg,
know eggs,
bacon,
sausage,
and you're allowed to eat as much as you
want.
Okay?
So it's not a calorie restricted diet,
it's Ad Libitum.
As long as you don't eat carbs,
you could have eight eggs for breakfast
and a rash for a bacon and you know,
whole chicken for lunch.
So the other theories,
theories of fat,
it's going to cause heart disease.
And the other theory is that the eat as
much as you want you to have a fat
person and as much as want,
they're going to get fatter,
right?
Because we think they got fat to begin
with because they ate too much.
And then you compare those people to
people you put on an American heart
association,
low fat diet,
and you tell them to calorie restrict my
repeating myself.
No,
go ahead.
You know the ice cream,
scoop size tuna salad on the lettuce
patty thing that we all went through at
some point in their life.
Maybe not you if you're naturally lane.
Anyway,
it all five of these trials and they'd
been done but not published yet,
and they'd been presented at
conferences.
The people on the Atkins Diet not only
lost more weight than the ones on their
calorie restricted American heart
association,
low fat diet that a whole American
people were supposed to eating.
So that refutes the eating too much
hypothesis because these guys on the
atkins diet can eat as much as they
want,
but their heart disease risk factors are
better.
Okay?
So they're supposed to die of heart
disease,
you know,
eat the bake and a clogs your arteries.
You fall over dead,
but they were healthier.
So it refutes the heart disease thing
to.
So there's the anomalous observation.
How do you explain that?
If dietary fat causes heart disease and
eating too much cause obesity.
So I write this article,
I lead it with this young Harvard
endocrinologist pediatrician who's
feeding low carb diets to his patients
at Boston Children's hospital.
He's like politically acceptable.
He's sincere,
he's at Harvard.
I want to ease people into it.
And then I talked about the Atkins thing
down below and how Atkins had gotten
pilloried back in the late sixties,
early seventies for telling people they
could eat these high fat diets because
we thought,
you know,
and what these studies showed and the
editors at the New York Times magazine
said Atkins is the elephant in the
living room.
Like get rid of this Harvard guy.
Put them down below.
Lead with the Atkins.
Okay.
I mean,
they know how to get people to read an
article.
So I write this lead,
I read it to my wife and a chair of the
American Medical Association,
the American Heart Association,
have a find yourself standing naked
nightmare in times square,
excuse me,
find yourself standing naked in times
square nightmare.
It's that all the advice they've been
giving to the American people about a
healthy diet for the last 50 years is
wrong and maybe atkins was right all
along and maybe both and I read it to my
wife and I say they will never run this
in a million years and I emailed it to
the editors and they don't change a word
and that's the lead of the magazine
article and then they put this picture
on the cover of the magazine,
which is kind of cheap looking,
porterhouse steak.
They didn't go to photographer to make a
delicious,
you know,
and it's got a pat of butter and the
headline is what if it's all been a big
fat lie and I didn't stop them from
doing it,
but I didn't know what to expect.
I knew it was going to be controversial.
Getting back to your question,
I tend to answer long winded.
I knew it was going to be controversial.
I knew it was going to be the most
controversial article they do run into a
friend of mine 10 years earlier,
had written an article about how
recycling is a complete waste of time
and money.
I had no idea what was going to happen,
no idea.
And I compare it to my boxing career.
Okay.
When I was younger,
I had,
when I was at Harvard,
I,
my best friend was a boxer.
He was a street Friday from Manhattan,
a Puerto Rican kid and a wonderful guy.
I mean everyone school loved them and
then uh,
he taught me how to box and we used to
box and the gym and I would do this sort
of Muhammad Ali imitation because that's
what I thought boxing was in 1977.
Then he actually had an amateur fight in
low mass and March 19,
77,
he got killed in the flesh,
Jesus.
And of course me being young and stupid,
um,
uh,
it's not enough to prevent me from
continuing.
So when I moved to New York,
watch the fight.
Yeah,
we were there.
There.
We didn't know what happened to him.
He danced into a right hook and went
over backwards.
Like it was frozen.
It was a plank of wood and his head
bounced off the Mat.
That is how I remember it.
I got notes.
My memory is right.
It's one of the scariest things is when
the head bounces one of the worst ways
to get knocked out.
Yeah.
And we knew it was bad,
but we didn't know.
He didn't die.
He went into was in a coma.
They took him to the hospital.
We went all home and we.
And then a week later there's just no
brain activity and they.
This how I remember it.
I hope I'm doing them justice by getting
the memory right.
Of course,
nowadays you can google it and read
about the article in the Boston Globe
and it wasn't article.
Anyway,
I moved to New York.
I'd go to journalism school.
I have a friend who is norman mailer's
nephew,
and Norman mailer had a group of people
used to get together at the gramercy gym
on Saturday mornings in New York.
Um,
this another long winded answer to your
question.
I talked about shaggy dog story.
So every Saturday morning we meet at the
gramercy gym,
which is the 14th and around Lexington
when it was back then it was a very
seedy neighborhood and it was,
you know,
a classic gym.
Yeah.
Classic boxing and some really,
like Ryan O'Neal was buddies with Norman
would show up once every three months.
And there was a guy who ran,
I forget,
it was a porn magazine that was sold the
Brown paper bag.
He would show up and then a half dozen
other people I had this friend Steve
Chow went on to,
uh,
um,
become uh,
barry diller's righthand man.
And yeah,
Hollywood would actually been the
Valedictorian of our class at Harvard
and we would spar and um,
I enjoyed it and I got into it and I was
getting the crap beat out of me first.
But eventually I,
you know,
I kept doing it.
And then I decided to fight in the New
York golden gloves and write about it
for playboy.
So the piece was called,
um,
what a life is a standing eight count.
Hello?
I'm sorry.
But this is after your friend died.
This is after my friend died.
Wow.
So anyway,
the point is kind of like going from
sparring to your first match now you had
a much more successful career than I
did.
I had two flights and I'm,
I'm one of the first one because the
Irish cop I was fighting got tired of
punching me and I finally thought if I
hit him back,
maybe that'll slow them down.
It worked.
But that transition from sparring to
being in the ring and having someone to
beat the crap out of you is like,
you just can't,
you cannot conceive of what it's going
to be like until you do it.
Right.
I mean if you can remember back to your
first flight and you might've been more
of a natural animal than I am.
I'm kind of a cerebral guy.
I think too much,
but that's what it was like getting this
article published.
Like I knew it was going to be
controversial.
You want me to tell you the end of the
boxing story?
Sure.
And one of my first fight,
I knocked out this cop from Staten
Island.
Then I was done.
I didn't want to do it again.
I didn't enjoy winning.
I did not enjoy knocking them out.
I didn't like anything about it.
This nose was not built for getting
pummeled and I was not a very good
defensive fighter.
And then the second fight I went up
against the guy who wanted,
you know,
this was the not the open category,
the 10 flights or less category and he
knocked me out in a minute and 37
seconds.
I had a friend who,
a photographer for life who came.
Norman mailer was at the flight to
Norman sitting there watching me get the
crap beat out of me and my friend was a
photographer.
Didn't have time to get her lens cap
off.
Basically she,
you know,
so that I have a photo that ran in
playboy with the article which was,
could she bring level when you see these
two big feet sticking up in this body,
prone on the ring,
you know,
did you get knocked unconscious when you
woke up?
How terrified were you thinking at all
about your friend who died?
No,
that's the funny thing.
Not at all,
but I thought about it afterwards,
so it's interesting.
Apparently,
you know,
I woke up in the ring.
I mean I stood up,
they raised the other guy's hand.
I don't remember any of that.
My memory of the fight at all,
a little bit.
A little bit of like these roundhouses
whizzing by my head and I had this
tendency I would like pull my head back
so I'm pulling my hands down instead of
terrible instinct.
Natural for some strange reason.
It's very difficult to teach people to
not do the worst thing.
Yeah.
And you know,
if my career had lasted past that fight,
my very good coach would have broken it
down to me.
Would've said don't ever do that again.
And you know.
Anyway,
I,
my memory is I,
I'm sitting outside the ring and the
doctor is saying to me,
do you know what your name is?
Do you know what you know?
So there's a period of my life was
clearly conscious,
but I have no memory of it.
Um,
then they,
they make you go to the hospital
afterwards to make sure you're not going
to die overnight.
And that was in the emergency room and
there was a guy next to me who had had a
motorcycle accident and cabot cut him
off and he had the same.
We were talking,
he was about my age Hispanic and he,
um,
you know,
this thing where there's no way you say
the next thing I remember.
And then there's this awareness that
there could vary.
It could very well have never been in.
Next thing I remember,
you know,
the moment could have just ended there
and that's what I started thinking about
my friend.
But I was too busy getting mad at the
hospital attended,
who kept telling me that my nose was
broken and I kept saying,
my nose isn't broken,
asshole.
This is the notes.
I was born with a man that's a broken
nose,
know broken nose when I see one,
but anyway,
that's,
that was a little bit.
So I published this article.
I've got no idea what's going to happen
and you know,
it was like just the universe.
I mean,
first of all,
there's an enormous amount of media
attention,
so I'm doing tv shows and radio shows
and people are writing about me,
but people are attacking me because the
implication is not just did the
nutrition,
obesity community screw up,
but my journalist friends who have been
covering this field screwed up that they
got the wrong story.
They missed the story that I found and
nobody wants to think like that.
You don't want to think you're bad at
what you do.
Right.
So you know,
friends or writing articles about me,
you know,
one woman journalist in Boston or used
to be a good friend who thought it was
one of the five best writers in the
country,
science journalists in the country until
I wrote a piece that came to a different
conclusion than a book she had written
on obesity and the headline and Newsweek
was it not the carbs stupid,
you know.
Um,
the center for science in the public
interest did a piece called big fat lies
cover of their newspaper.
Basically explaining how I had screwed
up on everything I had screwed up.
Another journalist who had written a
book on obesity,
did a piece for reason magazine about
all the ways I had screwed up.
And Luckily I hadn't screwed up in any
of them so I could get back at them and
take them down.
But when you did get back at them and
take them down,
you're talking about a time where,
I mean
year was this,
this was 2002.
So you had a blog,
did you have none of that?
Oh,
well did you publish a center for
Science?
And the public interest piece,
they wouldn't even let me respond.
Reason magazine was interesting.
I called up the editors and I said,
look,
this is just complete bullshit and you
got to let me respond.
And they said,
okay,
they didn't care because they put it
online.
So with the is going to write for them
for free,
let them write for them for free,
you know,
and the more controversy brings more
readers.
So I spent the weekend,
I remember I wrote like a 9,000
word response and there's still some
great stuff in there were,
you know,
even the very end of this thing,
I was pointing out every way this guy
had screwed up,
like taken down my article by saying I
made mistakes when he was the one making
mistakes in that last line was something
like he had called my editor who had now
bought this book for a lot of money.
He had called my editor on the gate use
the last night.
It's called them Richard Seagull or
something.
So the last line of the book wasn't just
the final word.
My editor's name is not Richard Segal,
it's John Period,
you know,
9,000
word takedown and this guy ended up
never writing for reason magazine again.
Either graduations.
Yeah,
he got rid of an asshole.
So
analysis,
it's the human ego is shocking and
horrifying because that's the only
reason why someone would look at what
you wrote and step back and look at what
they wrote and decide to attack.
Instead of deciding to go,
wow,
this guy went deep with this research.
I need to really look at this and I need
to really find out whether or not I've
been incorrect and I need to really
reevaluate what kind of advice I've been
giving to humans.
Think about the hundreds of thousands or
maybe even millions of people that have
read articles from these people that
gave them poor advice and that advice
adversely affected their health
directly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But again,
which that instead they cover their ass
enough program could do that.
They are wave that's remembering,
you know,
dietary mushrooms.
We're a member of my brothers is at low
dose asset thing,
so it's like I could really transform my
personality.
I could become a different person.
I.
Have you tried it before?
No,
no.
I'm a little that I'll become a.
I'm going to try now.
That's what's going to happen.
I have to,
uh,
let me know after the show.
I have to have to be able to get to
burbank.
Burbank on acid.
Best Way.
Yeah.
There we go.
Thank you.
Instinctively know where Jay Leno's
garage is?
Yeah.
It'd be like a beacon,
like seat above.
You know how you have a three d map and
it's got that little balloon where your
relocation.
Okay.
Were there.
Hey,
I live in Oakland.
We don't need it.
We don't need help with cyber up.
There were good.
The,
um.
Anyway,
so yeah,
it's just,
it's a natural human tendency.
Wish you wish somebody would say,
Jesus,
I never thought of this.
That's all they need to say.
They have to say,
we never thought of this.
This is an interesting take.
Clearly the editors at the New York
Times magazine are really smart.
People thought this was interesting,
the fact checkers fact check that
there's no mistakes.
That's why at least I was safe there
because they're really good fact checker
that didn't rely on me.
Why don't we,
and it just doesn't happen.
I mean,
it was funny.
Even afterwards I start doing this book
and now I'm going to interview hundreds
more people and you would expect that a
lot of the scientists aren't going to
talk to me because they're going to be
so mad at me about this article,
but most of them actually were good.
There was one scientist I wanted to talk
to specifically because a guy I was
talking to said he hated your article.
I thought it was total crap,
so I sent him an email and I said,
yeah,
I'd like to interview you.
I'm right here.
He thought the article was total crap
and I'd like to know why,
because if it was,
I want to make sure I don't make those
mistakes again.
And he said,
sure,
as long as you make sure you check all
my quotes because I don't trust you to
get my quotes right,
because that was another story that was
going around at the time and two weeks
later we get on the phone and he says,
you know,
I got to apologize
when I read your article was so pissed
off by the title,
what if it's all been a big fat lie and
your holier than now smarter than we are
at attitude that I never actually
thought deeply about what you're saying.
And I pretty much agree with you now
that I've read it again in context is
everything in these things.
So.
And I noticed that when I lecture,
so I give a lot of lectures.
I talked to the grand rounds and medical
schools.
If somebody introduces me to a room full
of doctors is this is a very well
respected journalists.
He's won all these awards,
including these influential public
health awards.
He's written this incredibly thoughtful
provoking book and we managed to get him
here to give you the arguments.
The doctors will be completely receptive
to everything I say.
I've also had people introduce me as,
yeah,
here's this Guy Taubes.
He wrote this big book,
he says,
everything we say is wrong and he's
going to give a lecture,
and now it's like they're tuned out from
day one.
From the moment I opened my mouth,
they're looking for reasons not to
believe a word.
I just crossed post sitting.
Exactly,
and then they're looking at the phones
five minutes later and checking their
email.
It sort of.
So context is everything and by making
this article as controversial as it
could with putting actions in the lead
and porterhouse steak on the cover and
what if it's all been a big fat lie and
I actually wasn't calling it a lie as a
lot of mistaken assumptions,
a lot of bad science,
but nobody lied.
Did you create it,
the title?
No,
but I didn't.
That's always what happens,
right?
I didn't reject it on there so I get
right title,
but that's the thing.
So it got me a big book advance.
It made it exceedingly controversial,
but it turned a lot of people off
because they were being accused of
things they didn't want to think of
themselves,
especially the lie.
Well perhaps the dam,
but initially,
but over the course of time it's got a
lot of support behind it now,
but so many people you've been
recommended to me by at least a half a
dozen people that I deeply respect.
Well,
this is the thing.
It's,
it's an extraordinarily powerful
intervention.
When you experience and you weren't even
overweight,
you know,
this is a good point.
Yeah.
Two things that you know,
when I talked to my colleagues about
this,
I say it's like you're playing in a
poker game with a thousand people in the
establishment and they cheat because
they all talk to each other and they
share cards and they show each other
what they get.
They tell them what they're going to
bet,
but God keeps stealing you for aces.
You've got the best hand,
you know,
and the best hand is you shift your
diet.
You get rid of the carbs and you replace
them with fat and it does remarkable
things to most people.
Not all.
Okay.
Because I want to talk to the people
that it doesn't work on.
I really do.
I want to know what they're actually
doing.
The problem with people when they,
you know,
it,
it's so,
it's so subjective and it's also,
you don't exactly know how they're doing
it,
what,
what their diet is like in terms of like
how would they cutting out carbs,
what kind of nutrients are they taking
in?
What's or what's the rest like?
I'm sleep.
Are they getting.
That's the thing.
I mean,
I have a friend,
a diet book author.
I think one of the smartest doctors out
there.
I'm always,
whatever he says,
it's always worth listening to.
He believes that when people fail in the
die,
it doesn't matter what age they are,
what sex they are,
when the Diet doesn't return them to a
relatively healthy weight,
he believes it's because they're not
conforming to the um,
I disagree with him actually,
but again,
he has more.
Any Diet period.
No,
the low carb high fat diet,
so you know,
maybe they're reading too many nuts and
there's carbs and nuts or maybe they're
lying to him about what they're doing or
they're still having the occasional
sweet and clearly there are people who
try to compromise on these diets.
If I compromise,
I mean you've been hearing so long that
fat is bad for you,
so I,
I'm sure I'm going to restrict,
you know,
sugar and grain and starches,
but I'm also gonna restrict fat.
Now you're reading skinless chicken
breasts with green vegetables and you're
not even putting butter on it and it
tastes awful and nobody's going to stick
to that diet anyway.
And in order to give the skinless
chicken breast some flavor,
you got to marinate in some sugar,
right?
So,
and the protein and they didn't wanna
eat a high protein diet because you're
going to convert the protein to glucose,
some of those amino acids and that's
going to raise blood sugar and that can
be a problem.
So maybe they're just doing them wrong,
but there are a lot of hormones that
influence fat accumulation.
So this is rumors had the Germans and
Austrians had concluded,
maybe I didn't say this,
I can't even remember what I.
I've been doing this book tour,
so I got it.
Germans and Austrians Research said,
look,
this has got to be a hormonal metabolic
issue.
The whole idea that it's just calories
in,
calories out is it's an explanation.
It's like somebody gets heavier,
they take in more calories than they
expend.
We know that it's like somebody
accumulate energy and their fat tissue,
they were accumulating energy in their
body,
which means they're taking in energy
more than they expected.
That's just a description of what
happens.
It says nothing about why,
you know they're clearly.
Hormones play a huge role in fat
accumulation or men and women would look
identical.
Okay,
so boys go through puberty,
they lose fat and gain muscle.
Girls go through puberty,
they gained fat and very specific places
like not everywhere,
you know,
place.
It's designed to drive the boys crazy
and get some procreation going.
And that's all hormonal.
It's all estrogen and the girls
testosterone and the boys,
you know,
little mix going on.
It doesn't matter how many calories
they're consuming,
so these Germans and Austrians would say
it's,
you know,
it's clearly a hormonal thing.
I meant the only way you could explain
obesity is a hormonal dysregulation,
and then in the sixties we learned that
insulin controls fat accumulation,
dominant hormone,
but these other hormones play a role as
well.
So stress hormones play a role,
and sex hormones play a role,
so estrogen and testosterone both
inhibit an enzyme called lipoprotein
lipase that when it's on your fat cells
basically pulls fat out of the
circulation and into the cell.
That's a simplistic way to put it.
So when you're pumping out estrogen and
testosterone,
you're inhibiting this enzyme which
inhibits fat accumulation.
Then you get older,
you secrete less.
These hormones,
women go through menopause,
they secrete less estrogen.
The light bulb protein lipase is
upregulated on their fat cells,
so you get more of it,
so it just starts accumulating fat.
No matter how much the woman wants to
eat or exercise,
and this is why they put on fat when
they get older.
I think women are program to put on fat
when they're pregnant.
Men are never really programmed to put
on fat,
but women have a fat accumulation
program when they're pregnant and it
sort of kicks in a little bit as they go
through menopause until I think
historically when you look at the
anecdotal evidence,
uh,
you know,
older women have a much harder time
losing excess body fat,
even on very calorie carbohydrate
restricted ketogenetic diets and it
would be completely understandable.
And the argument I make is that the,
um,
it would still be the best diet,
still be the leanest.
They could be,
you know,
for all intents and purposes by getting
rid of carbs,
but it does not mean that it's gonna
work or it's going to work as much as
they wanted to because of these other
sex hormones and the influence on body
fat as well.
And perhaps the only way to adjust that
would be extreme exercise,
right?
Like then don't have to go crazy
crossfit or start running up hills with
weights on them.
Something,
you know.
And that's a question I don't know,
and that wouldn't address it.
That would be sort of a temporary fix,
you know?
So you might be able to stimulate some
more,
even testosterone production,
I mean,
uh,
but temporary fix,
unless you continue that activity.
Yeah.
And,
but the problem is,
if it may be virtually,
you know,
again,
I,
here's my issue with Cri.
I don't know,
there was a harvard psychologist in the
50 forties and fifties named William
Sheldon who came up with this idea.
I'm gonna.
Need some googling here,
by the way,
I have three different fundamental body
types.
So there's an echo more Sunday mezzo
morph.
And uh,
what was the endomorph which is the
obese one,
endomorph endomorph.
And he said,
and which the thin what act?
So he said,
you can no more,
you could starve an ectomorph and you
don't turn them into an,
you can starve an endo more if you don't
turn them into an Ectomorph,
you turn them into an a macerated
endomorph.
Okay.
It's like you cannot.
And I don't know if it was his metaphor.
Mine,
I forget now you,
you can't starve a basset hound and turn
it into a greyhound and you just end up
with a basset hound.
Genetic factors determined by the
environment with our ancestors
developed,
uh,
and the environment in the mother's womb
and the,
you know,
uh,
and it's not necessarily,
like I said,
genetic and it certainly biological
factors.
Who knows,
maybe that gut biome is involved.
I doubt it.
But there's also the shapes of the
bodies are radically different.
That's the thing with the shoulders and
morphs.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My brother was an actor.
I mean he was,
he was always tall and thin and he got
one 95.
He was buff,
but he wasn't.
I could put on muscle much easier than
him.
I could put on fat.
I had a friend who was a taekwondo
champion in the eighties and he was six
foot two,
six foot maybe three.
And he fought at 147 pounds.
Yeah.
And you wouldn't get anywhere from six
to.
When I start,
I'll start with,
I'll starve to death at one 75.
But it was in his hands.
It was in the shape of his face.
He was very narrow feet everything.
It's just.
And that's how his body.
So part of this alternative hypothesis,
which I find so you know,
we believe today is,
you know,
the conventional thinking is how much
are we next besides drives,
how much fat do you accumulate?
And the alternative hypothesis is that
how much fat you accumulate is very well
regulated by the human body.
Other you could change that regulation
by changing the macronutrients.
So people who fat tissue doesn't want to
accumulate fat,
who are constitutionally lean.
Your body when they eat a meal,
they can't store it as fat temporarily.
They get a burn all those calories.
So the way they'd burn it in prior to
the 19 fifties,
a clinician studying obese,
you talked about the impulse to physical
activity.
So you eat,
you know Lance Armstrong eats a thousand
calories of pasta and his body doesn't
want to store it as fat.
It wants to burn it.
So he goes for three hour bike ride
after lunch because his body's trying
desperately to get rid of those calories
and it doesn't want a storm is fat.
I have the thousand calories a pasta,
my body's happy storing fat and I'm
asleep an hour later.
But I'm not thicker and fatter than
Armstrong because I'm asleep.
I'm asleep because that's the way my
body processed carbs.
But is that a case of nature or nurture?
That's nature.
Hundred percent.
But it's.
No,
it's not because the nurture part is
healthy diet influences.
So if I have exclusively fat and
protein,
if I'm eating a key to genic diet that
I'm minimizing fat accumulation of my
body wants to burn more calories.
So I am closer to being a lance.
So Lance Armstrong can be lean on his
high carb diet.
I am closer to being Lance Armstrong,
like closest on a diet to absent doll
carbohydrates.
But I'm still,
you know,
now I'm just a bigger individual.
I mean,
it's interesting.
We were talking about,
uh,
you know,
I was talking to a friend of mine who
was a freshman manager of my college
football team.
So this was harvard.
Okay.
It was division two football.
It was a lot of smart,
you know,
guys who couldn't make it in division
one.
We had kids who went to Harvard because
they didn't get scholarships at Holy
Cross.
So they went,
okay,
I'll play football for Harvard.
They were local 19,
76.
My senior year,
the biggest kid on our team,
Danny tickets weighed 265 pounds,
six foot five from our standards.
Who was enormous.
He went off to play for the Chicago
bears for five or six years.
I think we had one other offensive
lineman who was to 65 also six,
four,
six,
five,
maybe two this year.
Harvard football team,
a smart kid,
same socioeconomic status.
The entire offense have they got I think
12 players over 300 pounds.
His cronies guys were enormous.
I mean there are six slash seven,
300 pounds.
They didn't grow people that big when I
was growing up.
I mean I could say maybe I didn't see
him.
Maybe they weren't around.
Maybe they were six,
seven and they only weighed 2:30
because they weren't being bulked up.
So they were playing basketball instead
of football.
I mean,
I could imagine ways that that
confusing,
but from our perception,
if you look just what happened when I
was a kid in early 19 sixties there,
as far as I know,
there was one,
300 pounder in the NFL and the AFL,
two different leads back then.
Bob De remember his name,
he played for the Boston Patriots and
his head was like small compared to his
body and he was a big fat guy.
You know what is there now?
Twenty,
30 per team.
Well,
here's a good example,
big George Foreman from 1970,
whatever it was when he fought Joe
Frazier,
he only 217 pounds.
Is that George?
Only way?
Yeah,
I mean when he came back,
when he came back,
when he took a long time off,
he ate himself to be well over 300
training.
All the fat from the George Foreman
Grill
making low fat grows even after that,
but back in those days when he was a
terror before he fought Muhammad Ali,
who's relatively small.
By today's standards,
I mean if you look at a UFC heavyweight
champions,
steep emile chick,
I believe Steve a walks around about 240
pounds and he's small compared to Brock
Lesnar who's 285 pounds.
Like here's a good example that Jamie
just pulled up from 1927 guy blow your
nose man.
You figured me out the other one.
Okay,
here everybody could hear it.
Trust me,
they can hear it.
I'm 190 pounds Morris read but bad drew
grow.
How do you say that name B,
a d,
g,
r o bad bro.
That grow.
He's growing bad.
That's why he's only one 90.
He's six foot tall.
100 90 and this is 19,
27.
He played offense and defense for the
New York giants.
So that guy is 10 pounds lighter than me
and I'm five.
Eight.
Yeah,
he's six foot tall and he's a pro
football player,
which is fucking terrifying to me.
And then you go to 1967 and you've got
Alan page.
He's six foot four,
245 pounds.
A relative giant in comparison.
Then you go to 2006 and you have boy,
say that name.
How long have you got?
A lot.
Nada,
Nada.
I think you don't pronounce the
Gentleman Pranab.
She is.
Hello?
Nada.
Okay.
And he is six foot four.
Three hundred 35 pounds.
He's got a big old gut.
Him could lose some weight.
It's 45 seconds.
Wow,
that's insane.
So He's a giant.
I mean people are just starting left
tackle for the Dallas cowboys right now.
I forget his name.
Just Google left tackle.
Dallas cowboys or even a heavyweight
boxers today.
Tyrone Smith.
That's good to get a picture of it as a
big fella.
Okay.
Shirt off without the shirt off.
Let's go.
Pornographic.
Okay.
So they're not.
I mean,
people didn't exist like that when I was
growing.
Yeah.
There's this new heavyweight that's
fighting for the UFC.
His name is Francis in Ghana and he's
one of the most exciting prospects in
the UFC right now.
He's a heavyweight.
He's undefeated and he is fucking
enormous.
And uh,
he is probably.
Yeah,
go to that picture right there.
That far left far left.
Jamie upper left.
Yeah,
he's,
I mean that is a giant man.
Ridiculous,
brutal knockout artists too.
And um,
let me go to go see if there's a
wikipedia on his size,
but I'm pretty sure he's super lean
around 2:45,
something like that.
What does it say?
They're six foot four.
It doesn't say his weight right there.
It says waiting anywhere there.
Two 50.
Seven to 57.
Okay.
So he's 40.
He's 40 pounds heavier.
That may or may not be correct as far as
wait,
but close in.
I wouldn't be shocked.
He's one of those guys where he walks
into the octagon and you know,
when I do commentary,
I sit at a desk that's touching the
octagon.
So I'm sitting here,
there's a desk,
my notes are on it.
He's in front of me.
When he walks into the octagon,
I can feel his footsteps on my hands.
He's like,
he's made out of stone.
And then when he hits people,
just Jesus Christ,
you see the look on their face when he
hits him,
see if he can find like a,
like
quick highlight reel of this guy.
That was interesting.
Some of that,
I mean,
training has changed dramatically.
Like even for sure George,
I mean,
you know,
boxers didn't lift,
they didn't do resistance training,
didn't do any of the bags back thing
because he didn't want to slow them
down.
That's what they led this boom.
He's a giant dude French too.
Yes,
French.
But I believe originally from Nigeria I
believe.
And really look at that.
Boom,
big powerful guy.
Terrifying guy.
So here's the thing,
one of my pet theories,
I don't talk about this,
why I let my kids have sugar by the way.
Ouch.
The uh,
okay.
So one of the things that happens when
you increase insulin,
so the sugar,
the sugar,
because on some resistant that results
in chronic increases and insulin levels.
So insulin stimulates fat accumulation,
but it also stimulates the secretion of
insulin,
like growth hormone,
which is similar to growth hormone.
So the reason we grow is not because
growth hormone drives tissues and
skeletal muscle grow,
but it drives
into like growth factor,
which then works on a local level.
So if you have more insulin in your
system,
you can have more insulin like growth
factor and it's going to be more
bioavailable.
Um,
there's these proteins binding proteins
that float around the bloodstream and
they'll bind to igf growth factor and
make it so can't get into cells or can't
bind to the receptors.
So you would expect as populations,
as populations have become more intense
in some resistance,
you would expect them to grow to be
taller as well as thicker and fatter and
more diabetic.
And one of the classic observations as
populations become Westernized,
they get taller and this,
you know,
you look at medical records or army
records from,
you know,
the civil war and everybody weld them
and we're like five foot six and um,
you know,
now clearly the average height has gone
up and it's kind of leveled off a bit in
the United States.
But there's still countries in Europe or
it's gotten higher.
And one of the things that freaks me out
is when they go to Europe nowadays and
you're walking around a lot of
scandinavians and I feel petite Holland.
Yeah.
Rich Man in Holland is over six foot
tall.
When I was growing up I was definitively
tall and now I haven't shrunk.
I don't think it might be getting there
and now it's just like everyone seemed
six,
four,
five.
So the conventional thinking is they get
more calories,
I get more protein that you need the
protein for the growth and the calories
and that's kind of the explanation,
but it could be that they get more sugar
and that drives vertical growth as well
as horizontal growth.
And will that make sense?
Because don't bodybuilders like under
extreme situations,
don't they take insulin in order to.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because it'll,
it'll drive muscle development as well.
I mean,
again,
it works as a growth hormone and igf is
a growth hormone.
So could there be an argument for
bodybuilders to consume a diet that's
high in sugar in order to,
to spike up that insulin to,
you know,
now you're getting out of my area of
expertise again.
But it's funny,
when Arnold came over in the sixties,
the,
one of the advantages he had,
other than,
you know,
massive amounts of steroid consumption
was that he,
this,
I forget who his mentor was back then,
but they put them on a very low carb
diet because that definitely cuts the
fat.
So again,
this is far out of my area of expertise,
but you get a bodybuilder and they'll
tell you how they,
you know,
um,
uh,
you know,
oscillate between the high carbs for
development,
high fat to cut the fat and get down to.
I had this debate.
Do you know Alan Aragon?
No,
no.
Yeah,
yeah.
I know who that guy is.
So Allen,
we had a debate.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's very skeptical.
Oh,
it's a kind way to put it.
And I think it's a bit of A.
I don't get it.
I always wanted to ask him like,
Alan,
what you know,
you know,
that this isn't.
I'm arguing that that defined his
position because he has no calories.
It's just all about.
And you get people
to exercise and off field turn an obese
person lean.
And you know,
if that,
I mean,
the implication that it can happen,
but you know,
who the fuck is going to do it the way
you would have to do it,
you would essentially have to starve
your body.
Well,
but this is the point.
It's like I could get it done that way.
I know,
but it doesn't say any reason.
It doesn't say anything about why they
got fat to begin with.
I didn't say anything about the damaging
effects of sugar and I could inhibit
your kid's growth by starving them.
Right.
You know,
when they're going to be stunted.
But that doesn't mean they're growing
because they get to eat as much as they
want.
They're growing because their brains are
secreting growth hormone,
stimulate igf.
And that makes them hungry.
So what is he denying about?
I Dunno,
we rented
Bait in England that,
uh,
it was about a.
I don't quite understand what he was
denying.
That was the interesting thing.
He basically was denying that it was
about that obesity was a hormonal
metabolic disorder.
He had a denied that a journalist knows
something that he doesn't and that the
advice he's been giving and that what
he's been voicing over the years is
right and what is,
does a medical background.
Uh,
he's got no medical background.
He's a physical trainer.
Maybe it's an exercise physiologist,
he's no more doctor and nutritionist and
I am the,
um,
the point since I was looking for ways
to debate him.
So I found a clip,
a need internet,
one of his lectures where he was talking
about how there was one particular
athlete,
he was training a bodybuilder.
He had to get maximum caught for the
competition.
So he cut his carbs down and if he cut
the carbs preferentially you do that
because you're going to reduce insulin
and you're going to mobilize maximum
amount of fan.
You're going to get the most possible
fat out of the fat tissue by doing it.
And it clearly meant he believes what I
believe,
but some people just,
you know,
you got to establish what,
how did he respond to that?
He laughed.
Everybody laughed.
He got kind of embarrassed,
but it was a,
you know,
it was an interesting debate.
It was a fitness expo in,
I forget what,
you know,
red brick town in England,
one of these.
The reason why I keep bringing him up is
because I've been.
I've been contacted by fans of his have
been in communication with him at one
point in time and I didn't realize how
strongly against this proposition he is
or this.
Yeah,
well you should.
You should get him to do the show.
I mean,
he's very chatty,
talkative guy and he'll explain it to
you and then you could argue and we
could argue,
but what it does,
what does he say about the impact of
sugar?
Like does he deny all these things that
you're talking to them about bds and we
did not say this debate.
I would hate to get Allan's position
wrong,
but if he's implying that obesity is an
energy balance problem,
it's calories in,
calories out.
I.
That seemed to be the argument.
He was defending vociferously when we
debated.
That in turn means that the only way
that foods can influence your body
weight is through their,
a caloric content,
and that means sugar is,
you know,
an empty calorie than where she could
say about it.
Clearly not true.
If sugar actually does affect your
hormonal state and that affects the way
your body processes
fat.
I was so,
he went on insulin.
If he were to believe that,
then he would have been conceding that I
won the debates,
I'm going to say,
which he clearly doesn't think I did.
And um,
you know,
frankly I didn't because the crowd was
100 percent with him when we started and
it was like 95 percent with them when we
left.
But that's still pretty good.
That's what I would argue.
But uh,
and I learned my lesson that you can't
win a debate when you're going in and
everyone sides with your now why did
they all signed with him as they love
sugar now?
What was under,
it wasn't about sugars,
but the cause of obesity.
We were actually debating different
things.
Was kind of,
it was a weird situation.
I think I may have blocked it out of my
head,
but we were debating,
you know,
again,
my argument,
obesity,
I'm what I thought we were supposed to
be debating was whether or not obesity
is caused by consuming too many calories
or the macronutrient contents
influencing this sort of hormonal
metabolic regulation of fat
accumulation.
Um,
what we ended up debating was whether or
not the people in the audience would
rather be trained by Alan Aragon and the
physical trainer,
exercise physiologist or Gary Taubes,
the journalist because that's kind of
ridiculous.
It is kind of ridiculous.
And it was a bizarre experience.
And you know,
it was,
uh,
it was an interesting trip.
And you learn your lesson
conversations with people before and
that the problem with those
conversations is it's,
you're,
you're taking a very simplistic approach
to a very complex scenario.
You know,
if you did work out more and if you did
do all these different things,
you're going to affect your body and
your hormone levels.
If you start doing deep squats with
heavy weights,
you start doing dead lifts and you start
putting a weight vest on that hiking up
hills,
you're going to massively affect the way
your body produces hormones.
Your body is going to ramp up,
it's going to deal with these new
domains,
going to change the way you partitioned
fuels.
Since things are gonna happen.
See,
it's not as simple as a lot of people
like to point it out.
And then people see they seem to want to
do it as a math problem.
You know,
calories in,
calories out.
I
just said that I gave.
I was in Altadena on Sunday talking at a
skeptic society meeting.
We'll go to Altadena,
Michael Shermer,
Michael,
um,
and it was during the torrential rain
storms,
so it was touch and go getting there
because the roads were flooded.
But um,
just one guy sitting in the audience,
the front row,
um,
it was a calorie restricted or you know,
one of these guys who eats like eight,
he lives on 1800 calories a day cause
he's thinks he's going to live longer
and asked him if he wants to spar,
I'll get tired and about 20 seconds.
There's not a lot of.
Well,
the other thing with those guys,
there's not a lot of muscle tone,
right?
Because they don't have enough calories.
Dead Man walking so that anyway,
I'm going to live forever.
And Skeleton,
this is,
I did give a talk to the calorie
restriction society.
I'm digressing again.
This is in Novato north or San
Francisco.
And I got one of the guys in the email
afterwards said,
and I was explaining that I thought all
the benefits of calorie restriction come
from carbohydrate restriction because
there's a lot of evidence suggesting
that wouldn't make sense if it is
beneficial.
It's because these guys minimum minimize
insulin and igf secretion.
And um,
you can minimize insulin igf,
but just not eating the carbs.
And then you get the fuel,
the rest of your body,
so you get the calories you need to get
the protein,
you need to get the fat you need,
you don't eat the thing that stimulates
insulin.
Igf.
And after the lecture I got an email
from a guy in the audience who is part
of this society who said,
you know,
I'm going to experiment.
I should get back with him to see what
happened.
It was like four years ago.
He said,
you look so much healthier than all of
us.
And your argument was compelling.
I'm going to experiment to see if maybe
there's something to what you say and
I'm going to shift over from eating,
you know,
1800 calories of like 50 percent carbs
to 1800 or maybe 2,500
or who knows how many of protein and
fat.
Well,
I had Dr
Rhonda Patrick on the other day and she
was discussing some pretty compelling
evidence about the amount of time that
you eat during the day and intermittent
fasting and the importance of only
eating within a 10 hour period from the
morning.
You wake up to the time you stopped
eating no more than 10 hours and then
the rest of your day,
the remaining 14 hours,
no food.
Well,
and it's interesting because even,
um,
but she was talking about the massive
benefits of that and in terms of gaining
and lean muscle mass just from doing
that,
losing body fat just from doing that.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm,
I'm skeptical of everything.
I try to be as skeptical of my ideas as
others.
Although people say I fail,
but I,
I haven't read those studies closely.
I'll get them to you after we get out of
send it to you and send you the,
the actual podcast itself.
I think you'll find it pretty
fascinating.
Yeah.
And you know,
the issue is,
I don't doubt it works.
I know people who had trouble losing,
you know,
significant weight on low carb diets and
then switched intermittent fasting and
broke through.
Um,
uh,
you know,
there are some people I know in the
field who I like,
who think that you might get excessive
stress hormone stimulation from the fast
thing so that the long term effects may
not be as beneficial as a kid agentic
diet where you're not a zero evidence of
that cortisol.
Uh,
that would be,
yeah,
my understanding,
I haven't paid a lot of attention,
but based on people with a carbohydrate
rich diet or people fat rich diet.
Let's Google.
I'm Steve Finney,
P H I n n e y and fasting.
I love this by the way.
It's like I don't need a memory.
All those concussions,
you know,
it doesn't matter anymore how many
concussions you have,
buddy.
I think between football.
And so you say between football.
I started thinking between football and
boxing,
I'd say five or six.
That's it.
No,
you got off light.
I did get off flight.
Steven Dot Finney on making a low carb
diet.
Sustainable.
We want to do Steve Finney,
a intermittent try.
Intermittent fast thing.
I'm uh,
let's see if we pull up low car
preserves.
Well that's obvious.
Uh,
cutting edge fat burning podcasting.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're done.
Go.
Whoa,
hold on.
That's true.
Between the world's most cutting edge
fat burning performance media plan,
the Keto Diet.
Okay.
Well anyway,
we'll get into that.
We,
you don't have much time left because
you're going to have to bail soon to
catch a flight.
Um,
so I don't wanna I don't wanna make you
miss your flight,
but this is um,
you know,
another thing that people can look into
once they're done with the intro thing,
even the intermittent fast.
And the interesting thing is there's two
ways to think of it.
One is,
well,
okay,
your reading life,
fewer calories and that's how it works,
right?
And the other is you're maximizing the
amount of time during the day when
insulin and igf are low and when you're
saying eating fewer cowers because
that's not necessarily what they're
talking I'm talking about,
is taking time and allowing your body to
process all those nutrients.
Yeah.
And not using the resources that could
be developing muscle and in building
your body up.
So that would account for the increase
in lean muscle mass simply by following
this intermittent fasting program.
Although it's interesting,
I don't know if you had this experience
when you went on the Ketogenic Diet.
So what I want to,
because you often read,
people say,
well you lose.
I was looking at a study today that was
done in one week study done like 1967
where they lost more protein on the
ketogenetic diet that a calorie
restricted diet.
They were all calorie restricted.
But when I went on this diet,
it was interesting.
My waist size went down and my jacket
size went up and I probably my upper
body,
my lower body doesn't work because of
the cartilage in the knees.
And the other wonderful things football
left me with.
But um,
you know,
I just,
I'm stronger now than I was when I was
in college.
I was working out three hours a day.
I'm going to tell how old are you now?
Sixty.
Look.
Great,
thank you.
Oh,
you look good.
Too Cute.
But,
uh,
anyway,
so what's the point?
The point is by changing the time at
which you reading,
and I believe you could probably eat
this many calories,
maybe need more calories by doing it.
It's not calorie thing,
it's
a how does your body respond to having
more time is low insulin levels
basically and low more time at low igf
levels and I could imagine even in the
low carb diets when people are
prescribing them 50 years ago,
60 years ago,
they used to prescribe a walk before
breakfast,
which is interesting because that's the
time when your insulin levels are
lowest.
That's a time when you really mobilizing
the fat from your fat tissue.
Um,
so in that sense,
skipping breakfast,
prolonging the amount of time before
your first meal in the day would
actually maximize his time when you're
mobilizing fat.
I don't have people prefer fasting
cardio.
They,
they,
they enjoy that wake up in the morning
and having hard cardio or some sort of a
hard workout first thing in the morning.
Well,
and it's interesting because that's the
point of the day when they're most
likely to be burning fat rather than
glucose.
If they're not drinking a juice or soda
beforehand,
I could never do and I always wanted to
be able to do cardio first.
We certainly could.
You just don't want to know.
I ended up.
I'm just elevated the whole day.
It's like I'm dragging my ass.
Although I cannot wake up afterwards.
It's just my reality doesn't do it,
but it's even if I got you.
I got two kids.
I got a two boys,
11 and eight and I feed him breakfast in
the morning and I.
I Cook Him Dinner Maybe three times a
week.
My wife's a vegetarian so I got to cook
the meat if I want them to eat animals
they have their body clocks are entirely
different.
They have very different body types.
My youngest is not hungry in the morning
and my oldest is and my youngest at
night,
like if you put pasta in front of him,
he would just keep eating it and needing
it,
needing it until you finally just say no
more,
you're going to blow up.
My eldest in the evening doesn't care.
It's not interested in,
you know,
he'll eat a little bit.
He could skip dinner even like entirely
different body types,
but timing of their hunger,
which has got to be related to insulin
secretion,
other hormones,
you know,
bio rhythms,
so it's a.
everyone's different than that.
Biodiversity is a very important
consideration when you talking about any
kind of diet,
whether it's a Vegan diet,
a vegetarian diet,
ketogenic diet,
everybody's body responds differently to
different things,
but what I'm saying about getting back
to the case against sugar is we've got
obese and diabetic because of the sugar
and processed grains.
The people who became obese and diabetic
did so because of the sugar and the
process grades and that sense,
their bodies all responded the same
regardless of what their geno type was.
Right?
And now when you want to get them back
from the edge,
that's where individual variation plays
a role.
I mean that guy mcdougall pushes to
starch diet.
He's got people on his website who swear
that they lost a hundred pounds eating
only potatoes.
Don't you think though that a lot of
people,
when you start concentrating
on losing weight and concentrating on
being healthy and concentrating on your
di,
you make a concerted effort sort of
across the board.
So if you just go,
I'm only gonna eat sweet potatoes and
you know,
and like it just the very act of
considering your diet and being
conscientious has an effect.
Well,
it has an effect in many ways.
One of them is you do consistent things
that there are consistent things that
you don't do.
So like make the logo,
puts people on a starch diet and Atkins
puts them on a ketogenic diet and ornish
puts them on a 10 percent fat.
Mostly vegetarian diet and nestled thien
is,
you know,
a low carb diet and none of them,
all of them say,
don't eat sugar,
don't drink soda.
I don't drink fruit.
Juices,
don't eat white bread.
And they don't do it for the same reason
because it's good to stimulate insulin,
you know,
so.
And then when they benefit,
you don't know if they benefited because
they didn't eat meat or they didn't eat
gluten or they didn't eat sugar and
white bread and you know,
so the question then will become an even
if the ones who benefited like under
McDougall diet,
the thing that makes me suspicious is
the people we say,
I tried Atkins and it didn't work for
me.
And is that that they really try it.
They try it,
lost 60 pounds and then went back to
eating carbs and gained it back and said
the Diet failed.
Did they just find it too hard to live
without their pastries?
But once they make duke came along and
put them on the potato diet or did he
just tell him to say that because he
wants to point out that this works for
people that low carb does it and you
just never know.
Crazy.
Crazy world.
Yeah.
It's very hard to tell when you're
dealing with anecdotal evidence.
Right?
It's very,
very hard to tell when dealing with
personal experiences about what someone
says they did versus what they actually
did.
Yeah.
The one that's nobody knows.
And one of the great flow,
I mean there's tons of.
We could talk about the flaws in
nutrition research for another three
hours.
That'll be our next podcast.
No,
it's interesting because I'm doing this
talk with you.
I've never done it like two,
three hour podcasts before and you're
like still laser focused and I could
imagine,
I think I'm going to get in the ring
with you.
I could see it happening.
That exact thing that we discussed
earlier about that,
you know,
you need like five minutes of energy to
overwhelm your opponent and I could see
it happening here and I'm thinking,
okay,
if I didn't have a cold and I can
breathe through my nose,
I could take Joe,
we could go for seven hours.
I can wear them out and if it gets bad
we'll take out the drugs and the Tequila
and we'll see.
You know how there he's probably got,
you know,
I,
I gotta get back in shape there.
But anyway,
it's interesting.
So packet drugs,
it's been a long time.
Well I got a certain,
you know,
establishment veneer that I got to
present to the world.
Understand responsible,
I got to get people who wear jackets and
ties and button down shirts from Brooks
brothers to take me seriously.
Believe me,
as weird as it sounds,
a lot of those fuckers are listening
right now.
That's good.
And done it for awhile.
This is a really important subject and
this is,
wrap this up here because I just want to
thank you very much for writing that
book and taking the time to put it in
that research,
uh,
against probably a lot of people's
advice and my wife.
Well her,
it worked out in my,
in laws overall.
I mean it really is.
You've made a substantial impact and
like I said,
at least a half a dozen people that I
deeply respected recommended your work
and I'm really glad I got a chance to
sit down and talk about this and I think
a lot of people are going to benefit
from this podcast and this is one thing
that's just sort of piling on top of a
massive amount of data that's now
available to people that lets them make
better,
better food choice.
Well,
that's the one thing I was going to say
is what's really been the trump trump
card?
He's out.
What's really pushed,
uh,
you know,
what's allows us to win.
Okay.
Which we couldn't win 50 years ago is he
internet and that,
and people can try these dive.
Remember I said,
yeah,
we're dealt for aces.
The fact as you go on these diets,
it helps people.
It helps them a lot,
not everyone.
And we got distracted in some people.
I don't know,
maybe some people just have bad
reactions to cutting out all the carbs,
but for most people,
some significant proportion,
they give up the carbs,
they're healthier and then they can talk
about on the Internet and they could
share with people and they don't have to
live in the same town or go to the same
school.
So the word gets out and then other
people want to be helped.
And,
you know,
even with physicians,
it's like I got these doctors saying
you,
you made medicine fund for me again
because I can help people and that to
get spread around the Internet and they,
you know,
you create clusters and facebook groups
and it just,
you create momentum and you break out of
the gatekeepers.
It's no longer,
it's no longer just did I or did I not
get into the medical journal?
Was I influence enough to write this
review.
It's like,
wait a minute,
you said this,
but look at what happened to my
neighbor.
I want that to happen to me.
And so you get this kind of revolution.
It's slow and it's takes time.
And it,
you know,
there's a lot of resistance and the
vegetarian community,
they,
they resist it because the implication
is that a lot of people will be
healthier for the Ada.
Animals said to Michael Pollan's,
you know,
eat food not too much.
Mostly plants and for the,
uh,
obese diabetic individuals in the
country which represent virtually 50
percent of Americans,
maybe.
Mostly animals.
Well,
I'm hoping though that with the,
the.
I mean,
there's been some really significant
breakthroughs over the last few years.
We had factory produced meat that does
not involve any animals dying,
their initial meet from a dead animal
and reproduce it in factories and I
think we're probably just a couple of
years away from mass production or
something like that.
You know,
it's interesting.
One of the things that were in Missouri,
they're going to make low fat meat,
right?
Because I don't know.
I mean maybe with,
with what's going on right now and the
understanding that people have versus
what they
had only five or six years ago.
I mean,
I don't,
I think there's probably going to be a
market for high fat meat.
I hope so.
Well,
I'm gonna wait for you to try it and
telling that shows the benefit of being
a hunter.
So a kill my own meat is healthy as it
gets.
Yeah.
But I,
I sympathize.
I,
I completely understand where the
vegetarians and the vegans can.
I get it.
I,
and I admire them as.
I really feel like anybody could eat,
like naturally sourced eggs.
Like I have chickens and they don't,
they don't get harmed by me eating their
eggs at all.
They live a natural life and
everything's fine.
There was no cruelty involved
whatsoever.
And those eggs are extremely healthy and
beneficial and that's some of the best,
uh,
emails I ever got were from Vegetarians
who said,
you know,
I read your stuff.
I didn't want to like it.
I thought I'm intellectually open.
I'll read a couple of chapters,
decide it's full of shit,
and then I'll be able to close it.
And much to my dismay,
I found your argument compelling and
some of them start eating,
start eating meat again.
Some just add eggs back to their diet,
thanks to the shoulder and the crap and
find that they're healthier and happier
and they feel better.
And that,
that to me,
when you don't convince,
when you see somebody say,
you know,
hey,
I,
I get it.
I do see your point.
And I was,
I can change.
I feel like for people,
eggs are the best compromise because
you,
you can easily digest them.
It's very few issues whatsoever with
that.
And again,
if you have a yard,
you could have your own chickens.
Well that's not only that you can make
the,
it's they're like quick,
I mean,
you could scramble for eggs in the
morning and almost as much time as it
takes to poor salary.
I went to a ball cap,
so.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So it sounds like I don't have time to
eat right.
Um,
they don't take a lot of work to be
good.
Some people,
I mean,
my oldest son,
I can't get them to eat an egg unless
it's gotten motsa mixed in and maple
syrup port.
I don't know what it is.
Again,
it's one of these things,
it's like it's poison to them.
But listen,
Gary,
thanks so much for being here.
Really,
really appreciate it.
And I urge anyone listening to this to
check out Gary's book,
the case against sugar and anything
else.
No,
that's it.
Thank you joe.
Thank you.
Great.
Really appreciate it.
It's cool.
All right folks,
we'll be back tomorrow with Shane Smith
from vice hollow.